[Music]
n
n n
[Music]
n
a
[Music]
n
what's going on guys um right now I'm
getting people together
um probably go live in here about 5 10
minutes feeling a little under the
weather you know just got really bad
lihe headedness going on I I I I'll be
good I'm going to power through it I
think it's cuz I really haven't ate much
today uh but we are going to be going
live here soon I'm waiting for people to
pull up um got already almost 400 people
in there you guys always show up we
appreciate it we'll see you in a minute
man we'll see you in a
minute
[Music]
n
come
[Music]
n
a
[Music]
hey
n
[Music]
he
see that yeah
[Music]
yeah
n
[Music]
come
n
and we've got more than a dozen new game
announcements plus the old gods of
Asgard are here from Allan Wake 2 they
take the
stage for the first time ever it is
truly magical here live at the peacock
theater for Gaming's biggest night we
are streaming around the world
connecting millions of Gamers and fans
and getting you all stoked for our big
show but before that
it's our very first world PR PR of the
night oh they can't hear us dip down
said they can't hear us yes let's hear
it it comes from a Creator who has
already claimed game of past year at TGA
but this time going the title that
started it all for him a decade ago
here's the first ever look at a
beautiful remake of Brothers A Tale of
Two Sons originally created by direct
Joseph
okay event Garden
games
[Music]
oh
Bo oh we swinging for
okay oh chill we got D's that big that's
crazy see that it takes two influence
rubbing off chose Ferris in the
[Music]
building the bres the bres the bres
Remake 28th all right coming to all
conses wonder if they going to have the
uh Co-op mechanic going on with them
incredible and how perfect that right
after the world premiere of Brothers we
have the award best family game these
are together tear them apart depending
on how dirty you play and the nominees
are Disney illusion Island party animals
Pikman
4 Sonic Superstars and super
wonder and the game award goes to
oh I think I'm good adct they they say
they can't hear you lady Nate what
[Applause]
up thank you so much for this award this
is shared with all the teams of Nintendo
that worked on Super Mario Brothers
Wonder in my experience the team really
tried to develop a game that allowed
people to work together to play together
whether it was friends or just I'm not
talking for me personal experien is
nothing brings a family together more
trying to rescue an Empire a kingdom in
distress from the evil likes of Bowser
okay whether you're playing as elephant
Mario um Peach Yoshi or naot you might
have to mute your TV or something in the
back can hear stuff a little bit at
it congratulations Super Mario Brothers
wonder and now I have treat for all of
you three World in a row what first up
is the next game from Daniel moland the
creator of the TGA nominated independent
game
[Music]
inscription tell up with the stream a
little
[Music]
bit they somebody said like they hear us
with the oh no I don't think the stream
is messed up but Tony Bryan said
something interesting was behind or
something what's
this the creator of
inscription
okay very Arty
[Music]
farty
interesting oh they got full motion
[Music]
B very straight
okay all
right don't know what was that was going
on
there interview
[Music]
three
getting art style very
interesting almost gives me um Disco
elesium Vibes for some reason with the
art
[Music]
style
H the rise of the golden idol all right
all
[Applause]
right all right what's
[Music]
this fell by finy big finy in the
house oh they talking into Charlie Brown
[Applause]
[Music]
usual
J
okay 2025 another little art FY
joint I love this reminds me of my high
school days but the monsters I fought
weren't nearly as big as that you kids
these days with your giant monsters and
your social media and speaking of social
media Tik Tok livefest is happening now
across 50 plus countries on Tik Tok
check out the participating gaming
creators and don't forget to share all
of your favorite gaming moments on Tik
Tok with # gaming on Tik Tok okay we're
going to take a quick break but there is
more opening act after a very important
message cut scene
people oh I got the journey ended here a
place of Wonder and
awe we breached the cosmic fail and
reached a new
planet yet Generations
later this world remains Untamed okay
what this our reunion was for told our
path like destined to cross oh this so
adct I'm here for you now based on six
animes that addict
watched neata yeah it feel like that
energy
yeah no doubt yeah adct know everybody
here he know the power levels you know
who the boss who the real
boss
Enfield finish with Starfield we got
Enfield bro we live oh the matchness
come this feel like a cog game oh this
feel very Cog like oh what we doing with
the c l hat in the gliding what we doing
what we building what we
doing woo we got the stealth we got the
whistle with the gang oh let's go with
the gang look like it's turn Bas with
the crow seiz them
let's
[Applause]
go all right all right oh we got the
skill tree get your active puncher on
y'all come on
now this is SOC called right here oh we
doing the real let's get it we doing
that jet Le without the Wes what we
doing what you know about that I
recognize that
style I figured you would not use that
you are the chosen one I'm in I'm in
they got one for me
[Laughter]
y'all uhoh the Rogue trador has
fallen now I must take up their
mantle to Resto take back the real
former
glory to reclaim what Humanity has lost
oh what's this to venture forth Into
Darkness and bring the light of the
emperor to the Uncharted void
this look like some Warhammer AR turnbas
joint ruh ores this look like this joint
that I'm playing right now dangerous
Heretics like King joint they got the
budget Beyond
number turn Bas for sure CED with
cinematic all
right the choices I make will shape the
course of my destiny and with each
haunted step by Wonder where will my
journey end yeah they feel like their
universe is crazy yeah for Warhammer
joint out now Ro Trader okay so many
warham games man I can't keep
up wait you're Conor Kenway good thing
for you that I am here then this look
like you today you are to see a traitor
to the crow hanged by the neck for his
crime this look like the um yeah it's
like the the metag joint is death yeah
this The metag
Joint met
where do I start stay on the canals with
my good friend what could be better FL
me as always
Antonio in the end the Templar you can
play from um all the different
perspectives the
um the Odyssey
joint they got different
timelines who's a br showing us now
that's what's
up
NEX mhm in St get
that welcome back to the 2023 game
awards opening act
I'm here with another award this time
for Innovation and accessibility The
Gaming Community is massive but honestly
it should be even bigger and these
nominees are pushing gaming current
limits their teams have created softare
Ware and Hardware that make it possible
for people of all abilities to
experience the medium of gaming with
accessible features and technology that
get us all one step closer to a seamless
play for everyone these nominees are
doing the work and they are Diablo 4
Forza mot I think for this I picked Rush
Marvel
Spider-Man Mortal Combat 1 and Street
Fighter
6 and the game award go
K got another one I know I'm up too I
know I'm up too we got to see what Sol
score
at s said straight fighter 6 yes I'm
ahead
of category was introduced several years
ago I think we've seen a dramatic whole
industry towards making games more and
more access literally Drive list of
amazing nominees it just really to dve
that game remember he wanted to change
it at the end I think we've made the
most successful racing game people turn
10 baby keep the boot soft neck y I got
to beat them this I need one chip man
here are the players who have so many
great games to
play none of this would have been
possible without the amazing teams the
big thank you to our audio team for
their tireless effort championing for
accessibility and making this game the
best that it can be big thank you to the
UI team to our studio leadership team
and our accessibility leaders ship team
and last but last least Brandon Cole for
being our uh accessibility consultant
and partner for the last two
years we're really proud of the work
that we've been able to do so thank you
to the team turn 10 with one for us in
the building I got another one lined up
for y'all in a certain category don't
you worry about congratulations for is a
motor sport here at the game awards we
believe strongly in accessibility and
want to celebrate any game that makes it
a priority and our next developer the
odd Gent gemen believe that by making
their games and their company accessible
and inclusive they can develop new types
of gameplay with stories that everyone
can enjoy they created the following
game in a deep collaboration with
artists and developers from the death
community and we are very Master cheeks
78 got my Vaseline ready for S but I
think I'm going to go raw today pause
hit the like real Advance the line make
them forget about the awards what was
the first one the family one oh the
family one was Mario Wonder JD gaming
follow Super Chat prediction Xbox games
that would cause the most Buzz rise to
scale bound cell or buy Square what's it
y'all y'all wanted to acquisition at the
awards damn all right back to the show
all right what's
this all right so right now you're in
the lead by
one I and me and S are tied for two we
should end it now cuz you know it's
clear
[Music]
like one of the musical
jokes are you this like a
[Music]
rib
this is one them solve joints this one
of them Broadway play
joints and it's kind of crazy he don't
play games like that but he loves that
he loves the the the theater and the
Opera and all that this is Sol right
here look around me that's
all Z said this is a note look around me
and see everything I can
see at the pavement G pass oh yo don't
do that honestly I don't know no it said
come to Game Pass it
did Platinum is this the Platinum age
also can I please be paid in Platinum
I'd like to direct please and now I have
the honor of announcing the winners for
our five
Esports the nominees for best Esports
athlet they going through face Faker who
you got I got my man Z wo I don't know
none of them but I'm his name sounds
fire we only did best Esports
game sh I don't like their name is Faker
though what let me stop best Esports
coach oh the best Esports coach this the
guy that said he a
coach is it one of the guys say he a do
it this year take my name off the L and
game
too
Potter for best Esports event here are
the nominees we didn't do this3 League
of Legends we just did the game shout
out to the guy who get coach nomin slute
I'm being messy I know
the international Dota 2 championships
2023 and valerant champions 2023 let me
see Sports please come on damn League of
Legends is Beast out here I a hold leg
is real
best okay so you all said League of
Legend all right all right I said
valerant League leg all right come on
League I just gave won the league before
let's give it to leg let me get this one
and the game award goes to damn it did
you y jump down the window Dam no I
didn't jump out the window I knew that
that was going to
win Gladiator see I actually a lot of
static who's who got the static down is
it me or is it adct or JD gaming JD G
huge congratulations everyone I love
Esports i'ms
somebody do good are
HS all to the 1800 that's a shot
you it's time for another two World
premieres first up is the
lward back in 2017 so I think we can
trust them to crush it again this
is oh it was a microwave so he said I
heard a microwave earlier yo Michael
Kelly they pull up your whole your whole
dck look like Dragon Ball Z animation I
mean art
style is anything
is like anything that looks Ry Dragon
Ball Z style to you yeah yeah that's
Dragon Ball Z this is this is your this
your lane it's your lane cre dead cells
dead cells
[Music]
okay
oh this looks good cool little three
play it's three player right
mhm you think is Rog life what we doing
I told you you like these once the all
Styler like this attic is
in oh oh they got murder though I like
murder oh they what splitting people
apart they got real going
[Music]
on oh my God yeah yeah see I'm about
that
now we going to take it to the mature
thing
yeah there we
go yeah yeah yeah they down with all the
Dragon Ball Z characters just all to the
universe you don't even know what you're
talking
about M BR they down with them they down
with them I can see down with the
sickness mind blown all right come oh
for the people that make Thumper oh
Thumper is my joint they got the best
beat so now CG's in it he's in it C's
about to Mur I quote me in video game in
video game hey deep down you want on
here
yeah that's all
[Music]
with I'm telling you do not sleep this
is going to be fire if the dudes that
made Thumper had anything to do with
this this is one of the best Rhythm like
at the end Thumper made the time
scen the guy who worked the trash at
Thumper
the maintenance guy at the what whoever
is associated with du yall smart I'm
telling y it's going to be fire they
probably going to have a VR version oh
they they figh the embryo bosses I'm
telling y'all don't look at this
Thrasher we're from Thumper to Thrasher
Let's Go baby go get that who made it
what it's coming creature what platform
what we doing we ain't got the platforms
a yes Thrasher in case you didn't know
is from the same artist SL composer that
blew our minds back in 2016 with the
cold hit thumber I'm so excited we've
got another mindbending game coming from
him in 2024 special shout out to Samsung
Samsung gaming Hub who not to brag are
also throwing a massive game awards
viewing party over at Samsung's New York
City Flagship location with typical
gamer and Chica I wish I could be at two
places at once but the last time I tried
to clone myself I sparked a pretty
sizable fire in the MIT experimental
physics lab oops but we can talk about
that later let's check out what Sams is
coming out with we we can miss us with
that but we Starfield let's go Game Pass
oh Game Pass Sizzle trailer expand the
way you
game the way you g Samsung got TVs out
there y they like yo oh we got the
Double Dragon original I saw that play
3,00 games facts on more devices no
console required I knew they was going
to say that go required gra your
controller and apparently when start
playing now Phil was in Brazil
Game Hub they is outside with
these oh what's this oh this look like
Persona ly what's
this yeah this is this definitely
Persona like energy what's this Atlas in
the
building is this come on ad what we
doing it's it's uh
three oh letting you know Three is out
in stores go get that last one no it
comes out next month uh I think next
month now that's what I'm talking about
early February
[Music]
oh oh who got the
bosss MC Atlas that's the dark
hour and the next they only appeared
during the dark hour I had to turn down
the audio just just just for all this
uh this uh
music f is on his way okay I turned down
the audio guys just for the music uh
I'll turn it back up once the TR uh
trailer's
over do fight when it's it looks good
yeah I don't even have a good reason to
live for me or you or anyone just simply
existing
did you play the original Tri who or
this is one one that you missed out on
yeah I I didn't start Persona to the
fifth one
okay in that game pass as kid say he
Game
Pass I love how they put it down there
like it's like it's own platform you
know what I'm saying well he said we got
everything over here tacal we got all
that we that we the whole Persona that's
K say right
now yes I new persona a new Persona game
that is I still want to be Sydney but
enough about me make sure to stay tuned
as Google and the Samsung Galaxy Z
full he didn't play the PSP version damn
it's going to be an epic event just like
this next World premier world premere
it's the product of a surprise team up
between two nominated games tonight
let's check it out team up between two
games Dave the
diver the the the coolest Indie out Dave
the diver be messy game is
fire was it on Game Pass mhm I believe
so maybe
not indie of the
[Music]
year
Dave the diver drad so
expansion sum 15 DLC I can't believe it
it's almost time for our Big Show the
theater is filling up behind you right
it is this is pre-show show they did do
stuff out the
pre here are your nominees
for we didn't do it iron Mouse who name
sound fresh who name sound like is going
to win I'm going with iron Mouse with
qu or
whatever and the gameward goes
to I am come on man down with the team
he's a Lord he's a
Lord that's one of our peop out there
animated and sadly we're not in the
Matrix yet but she did send us a message
take
awaye I am so incredibly honor I've seen
her
on
Shing first and foremost I want to
express my deepest heartfelt gratitude
that's my girl Mousie you hear I'm
saying we outside she was doing she went
hard this [__] man I watched all the
streams all who brings all my ideas to
life thank you so much to my team we did
that that's for the team we brought it
home thank you so much it's all love
girl do your thing is all happening
thank you again
everybody congratulations iron Mouse
okay we're getting so close to the Big
Show but I'm not ready to let go just
yet and no I'm not a narcissist I'm just
a hoarder a hoarder of world and up next
is a very let these people run wild or
they're just saying this stuff she she
got her Ball is she
ready what a beautiful
world is this the better star of alone
or whatever another one
[Music]
m
like the
[Music]
music Someone said home girl needs
therapy the way she keeps
talking
present sludge the game never wanted to
manipulate sludge we got
you though eyeballs are are a little
concerning little little creepy little
creepy yeah the eyeballs with the sludge
and the green
go little
[Music]
concerning what is going
on why they talk like
[Music]
that we just going to talk like that a
whole podcast yeah that the whole
show Welcome to I
[Music]
up I can't kind of sounds like they're
like speeding up
the the video yeah like it's on to
[Music]
six World of Goo part to the sequel cuz
clearly C miss the first one but we here
now we here we here 2024 y'all get that
man that is satisfying to watch almost
as satisfying as the game award show
that's minutes away we have one more
huge World premiere a brand new fantasy
RPG from the creators of persona
345 and tonight they're giving met the
story character and gameplay let's do
this go for relax
yourself to the
Xbox that metaphor right here it's a
world where all people are equal and no
conflict exists much like the world His
Highness once dreamt of to put it
another way this is a
fantasy
uhoh the creators of every Persona every
fire joint Studio zero of a king is dead
without an air to wear the CR what will
become of the royal magic Fortress at
the border was raised by a human near
days ago you can only blame your King's
weakness who deserves Crown is this
turnbas or not turnbas I like he talking
that talk though he said he deserve that
Crown welcome and all to the inur oh he
did sh me the tourament for the I love
how they're saying what they worked on
yeah they like yo we everybody here is
dead nice everybody that worked on this
we tell what they work on
fact director Legend of everything fire
if only our lives were anything like the
world in your novel Our Lives mat is
going to go crazy tribal Purity or by
the differences that make us who we are
those are to his life little different
perspective on the clim right jrpg
goodness right there definitely turn
will see what manner of story you'll
weave let's do it you'll be a hero trust
me what are they are they turning into
that thing what is that thing you see
that interesting fall
2024 oh we got the okay so we next year
with it it's it's kind of interesting
that that's a series s and X this is
like the Video Game Awards why didn't
else but don't worry this isn't the last
you'll see of me I'm staying she like
you get me quick and I cannot wait
because this show is absolutely stacked
we have tons of if we see any of our
look at the crowd games and an
incredibly special guest a legendary
actor and performer of both the stage
and Screen the Muppet himself the great
Gonzo I have to ad
out I'm completely Star Struck and get
this the cast of the show based on the
Fallout franchise is here to debut new
look at the series The Vault is opening
in a huge yeah M break dancing okay
thank you all for going on this journey
with me you're the best companions a
host could ask for let's do the boss
level the 2023 Game Awards start let's
get it it's our Oscar
y'all not but we we got to
respect welcome to the game awards
2023 now here's your host got boys of
the game awards Jeff ke uh-oh we see the
drip oh we got the tops okay big money
oh going to come outy be all right all
right was that Dereck Rose
uh-oh got oh we came to the fish out
talk is heavy in the street he heavy out
here I a going front
it's a lot of money I'm pocket watching
a lot of money our 10th TGA a global
celebration of video games and boy do we
have a show for you I am so excited to
get this started together we are going
to recognize outstanding creative work
in games in 2023 and we'll look into the
future with an astonishing lineup of
world
premieres more than anything this is a
show about bringing our community
together
you both
sides age there more powerful or more
imersive than an
extraordinary video
game je got that crazy B look at look at
the
shandel great games Comfort us help us
understand different perspectives on the
world and maybe even I well that's what
makes this medium
differentes the actual things we play
are insanely special celebrate that for
the next few hours and we've got such an
amazing group of people with us they're
built by talented creators and teams and
many of them are here tonight Mr anuma
Mr fashi great to see you back what's of
the year
in Wild good luck you see looking around
like he did he said it Ain time Jeff is
early CH Mark Cy PlayStation's lead
system AR celebrating 25 of games Thank
you for here he got Sega to I got my
Sega shirt I got team behind Pizza
Towers here too what we got said Pizza
Tower he said yeah oh we in
there everyone's here Molina Jurgens our
best performance winner in 2017 for
hellblade welcome I think we'll be
seeing you a little bit later tonight
they said we going to see her later
tonight and we are also honed to
be family Haru and rioo who are
celebrating 40 Years of Capcom this year
and a game of the year nomination for
Resident Evil welcome guys it's so great
to have you with us now we have a big
show so let's get right into it to
present tonight's first award is last
year's winner of best performance please
join me and welcoming back to the game
awards yep we're going to do it the we
do it yo bro yo we got to have to wrap
it up be box I love you brother but we
we on time this year please let's see
what you let's see the drip you though
cuz your drip game is crazy you got the
Snak skin joint okay what we doing
Christopher Judge I just need you on
time brother that's all I need drip is
hard
though
oh what a
card good evening everybody the clock
starts now
please it is such a pleasure to be back
here I have such great memories but not
as long for to think my wife oh they
clouded on it okay they making fun of it
I like that I like that I like that yeah
hit the music get the get the sand man
going and the cane and all that if you
break the time limit that's right they
play the music on you early we know how
you do I get it I get it five minutes b
stand up here making long speeches I'm
going to stick thank you script no 8
minute speech like last year but fun
fact
my speech was actually longer than this
year's Call of Duty oh he got jokes oh
he got jokes oh he got jokes they going
to say Xbox tax brother be careful be
careful brother you was doing good they
going you know they going to say it I
can't believe that just they going to
say you going doing good you was doing
good they going to say that Jeff told
you to write that is there another
company I'll never work oh now you going
to act oh brother this is not good I'm
here to present the award for best
performance so in a year of games you uh
beloved
by and a claimed by and I said c these
actors delivered six
Unforgettable
performances and here are the
nominees best performance so who did I
say oh best yeah yeah yeah bro come on
he sold that demo he made me buy the
game I love camera though shout out to
respawn I love cam grasp oh St Bell who
who did you say I
said you're a little ahead of okay sorry
I'll be quiet my names aaran they won't
ever control me again ready for your
annual physical we have to talk I'm the
hero here can you hear me yeah big F
what up whoever wins what's up chilling
brother good glad to have you okay to
say yeah same take as long as you want
to
anything in your life and I dare you I
double dare you to try to break my
record 7 minutes 59
seconds who we got and the award goes to
keep in mind you're ahead of us a little
bit Neil
w wow we n of none of us got that so who
was it Neil no one even picked him for
even picked him
yeah oh look at Sam Lake in the building
oh they got the security on Deck oh let
you run on the stage this year let you
run on the stage this year you getting
tackled and put down I see Security on
every
aisle oh Jeff got the shooters on Deck
let you play around with interrupting oh
look at
Xbox who won that I missed it um XBox
say see you soon Larry Studios oh Xbox
just said
oh yeah I I had him winning too oh you
had a winning y I'll give it a shot
voice much very voted like my incredible
fellow actors and the nominees
unbelievable talent to be even
considered amongst you is is
extraordinary to swen to Lian to all the
writers to stepen Rooney the writer of
aarian uh to I'm going to forget
everybody uh to Pit Stop who worked so
hard the directors my fellow actors 248
incredible that gave it heart and soul
to and to my agents I will thank you
later I'm sorry they got to wrap it up
one thing I will say please if that's
okay the community has reached out to so
many of us at Lian and they were seen
and they were by this game when they
lost hope they felt isolated they alone
and this game brought them together and
gave them something to push through to
help them all and to you I want to say
thank you so much for see us salute
salute
Lan you're not Al in this none of us are
thank
you that man came with a full shalling
suit respect he in a dojo
[Applause]
heavy yeah I felt I felt that for B and
short so thank you uh there are lots
more Awards to come but now it's time
look ahead to what you'll be playing
next let's get to those world premier
the honor of presenting our first one
it's an
incredible true Renaissance Man please
welcome Academy award-winning actor and
New York Times best-selling author
Matthew
M uhoh I told you you see what he got
two microphones on the lapella of the
tuck the budget different this
year thank y'all for having
me
good to be here what's up everybody good
to be here with you at the game award is
he like voicing a character I was going
to come out and I was going to say the
line that has preceded me on my career
all right all right all right they told
me pretty much they said no no no don't
do that come out and say pew pew I
can't all right we'll see how that how
that how that handled I'm here tonight
because I have a world premiere for you
from Austin's own archetype entp oh
don't new dudes I'm also tonight because
the video game I'm premiering is the
first ever video game that I'm a part of
yeah these are like I think there old
school byway up in the joint when the
archetype team first reached out to me I
was excited about becom world but what
really turned me on was when they shared
the game's vision and my role in it I
will be voicing a character in this game
and all I can say is that I will have a
unique relationship with every player
death Road chain this
game time appreciate the invite moves
differently no problem no doubt
definitely the Veterans for your LED old
school good
bow I think
Drew they'll also AFF or your entire
civilization for generations to come and
personally I have had some experience
with time
dilation and now you can
too so now I proud to share the first
ever look
at all right let's see what archetyp
been doing they've been cooking up for a
while you know it's going to be good
let's
go oh we going Mass Effect energy
already Vibes
already hold on I'm getting a reading
please no
moo Max
wait Max archetype
entertainment what she found that day
was a mirror
irle it would be our Salvation yeah
aesthetic look fight celes
nice Humanity's greatest enemy what the
hell this look crazy that look
sick they found us what's going on they
got Decepticons out here like
an oh they got deeps on this planet we
got to go steals hunted us
down I knew they'd keep chasing us until
they ripped our ship part and I know
about the character models all too much
yeah the face is a little interesting
the face is a little interesting they
went for a distinct look clearly we both
knew the cost of using the
gates when you travel at
light
that it was only days for me but an
entire lifetime pass for her people are
saying Starfield to in chat
stupid please Tom just don't say Anthem
relax that's
that's I'm coming around on the AR sty
though for the for the face our service
no it doesn't look bad it's just
different it's
not correct seeds hope I like this this
space combat that's in there that look
kind of oh I think that's us right there
I like the aesthetic all Al together it
looks it looks really good oh oh here
gam play okay oh bro Mass Effect energy
with oh we got the climbing in the
traversal with the evil
deceptic oh let's go you know
everything's got to right there
though come to tr
oh yeah
yeah okay Exodus that that's the prequel
to Destiny
BEC that is a very exciting project
giving me some M Vibes and I appreciate
the team sharing the first glimpse of
gameplay
feel well now we're going to go right on
to another world Premier Premier
worldation uhoh W give it to me yes
let's
go oh I think I know what it is to
that's Jon it's time to get the FedEx
let's pop it that that's King's old
Throne after you took his knees King's
knees once we're here after I took his
King oh no oh God of War new God of War
DLC ragna just be better than Ragnarok
St
monio let's go boy master
thyself
tell me brother why exactly are you guys
feeling like you need to see a new IP
from son I'm kind of feeling that way
lately I must face this always I always
learn new stuff from them this this I
mean this is bread and butter you know
how how they give it to Xbox all the
time Halo gears infor no I get you I get
you I get you that's fair that's fair
with right now that's fair
that's see what he doing she
doing it look like that
Spartans
yeah what's the what is the name of it
RH Rock
Valhalla Valhalla make Hala that's been
played
out December when when oh you get oh
they get some free free okay now that's
ack that's nice free DLC that's nice so
be 2 hours folks
you might be able to crack four with it
we don't we got five there's a very nice
holiday Surprise Play Kratos and are
headed to
Val
comat go to ttch is way further ahead I
was on YouTube the team in Santa Monica
Studio are fans of their fans and are
offering
OFA I'm usually do thate like
download days on December 12 they need
to do something nice
that's from small developers in
Australia I love that
thiss this is the remaster of the
remaster company and their next project
is equally
exciting
too bad yeah from the crat is a goose
game house
housei to toi that's
right I love that
name I know that name was funny look
what is going on this is in the
background I see nothing at it your
phone disappeared there's a big thing in
the this please wrap it up oh hell no
watching this yeah n come on we in let's
go y'all can play this one I'm I'm out
we do come out n doing this we not on
this you know what games like this
puzzle me they always give like this
realistic like aesthetic and then they
give you these characters that look so
goofy and it's like why you got it's the
legs that doing it for me the legs I'm
like
these
like quasi
P character come on F we not in we not
going
Platinum they just jumped into F's
head they did and it's empty that's
right right now it's empty they look
hilarious
though you get out me they are the
funniest looking bottles I've ever seen
what is keep bouncing their knees to the
beat like that the nose just keep
feeling it
just the other okay there little steps
and that's big walk Little Steps big
walk yeah super fun right I did a play
test of that game about a year ago and
had so much fun it is a very special
game I'm honored we got to share it with
you here at the show all right while
you're watching TGA head to TGA steam
deck.com right now we're doing another
steam this time new steam H display
enter now only during the live show at
TG steam.com for a chance to win one of
100 oleds all right trust me we are just
getting started guys there are so many
game announcements Awards and musical
performances ahead including the
your just wa we'll be right back thank
oh no oh is this uh prin of I'm here to
save a
prince are you now
prin Hassan has been kidnapped Take the
Lead
s you I think this actually looks pretty
good I like was about to say actually
looks nice BR bring back my
son
strange this path before and they got a
little extra production value between
the stages our kingdom engulfed in
flames there's nothing you can do to
stop me oh he's straight atrio move fed
him yeah he did the the master chair
wasn't the old pin like the old old
still alive yep way back you seem
stronger it blew your mind back then so
good the anation yeah oh back in the day
back in the day you were like oh this
looks realistic yeah that was a huge
jump Technically when prin pers came out
in animation are you remember until that
time we got stuff like to
friend
KS don't know I'll do whatever it
takesy I'm really
old j a little too much like flash and
stuff I want to see more gameplay on
that like fair enough we've seen a lot
of gameplay on that though we did we
have but I mean oh attic right here it's
attic and dip down this is dip down
right here
said
gam this is dip right here this for the
dips Dip set Dip
set oh look at the eyes on that one
character what the hell is that a fish
then he going to make a question talk
about save the world if you had to pick
four if you had to pick four Lego
characters with the powers of Music the
galactic gargoyles at it again Yep this
is going to be us we going to have to
deal with the trivia on this I'm going
to have to learn the law
[Laughter]
now come on this does look fire oh man
this is so not me but
respect yeah I mean if I want to play
fortnite I'm going to play fortnite like
come on but it's I mean it's a huge
follow bro this is
huge but what are people going to choose
right are they going to play fortnite or
play this that's a good question I think
what it would leg depends it depends if
they give you reasons to play this in
fortnite true true you're right it's
always who they Associated the IP and
all that if you beat this you get if if
you beat whatever this is you get like a
Lego skin or
something said don't
hit no hay no hay on the fortnite
nintend I knew Nintendo d was all over
this he's like look I knew he was all it
the thing is is you can't really hate on
something like fortnite cuz it's so huge
like yeah oh yeah now it's a monster mhm
you're in the very minority if you hate
on it absolutely I'm old man throwing a
rock at the cloud way bigger than Halo
I'm kidding I'm kidding I mean but he
ain't more R tracing than Halo
infinite as far as impact cannot deny
Lego fortnite wow that's going to be
crazy I want in the building it's out
already
yeah get it now please welcome a former
game of winner for best performance
let's get it all right now if you come
out here oh my god oh we getting the
hell blade we getting the hell Blade no
if you show it again we better get some
combat if they show hellblade I swear to
God if they show another
behind I'm proud to introduce to you to
one of my favorite bands oh we doing
music oh man all right y'all it's the PE
break that oh my God what is this
[Music]
what in the charlatan is this what in
the Good Charlotte is going
on Ro like going one and
twos you know what's funny they they
they start playing gameplay in the
background wi about that let's go some
actual
combat s got the live B oh she going she
making an
album that crazy she's doing like a
quick redress right now she comes back
she come on back she start spitting
[Laughter]
[Music]
balls
yo hell blade budget is crazy she's
roasted
[Music]
marshmallows those marshmallows after
like yo that Xbox budget got us doing
whatever we want to
do see okay so I I would like I you know
I've always said this I hate these
theatrics at these kind of shows right
however if they were to show a lot of
game playay during this this it like
yeah show me some gameplay I feel like I
have a little screen in the back yeah
show me that combat that budget is
different so we just make music videos
for no
reason just to Hype up the game yeah
what that's right yo I'm not going front
on the aesthetic though the aesthetic is
fire it would be nice though G play in
the background though it would
be I agree I agree keep the keep keep
the gaming in the Game of War I respect
that yo he tearing them drums up you
can't tell him he's not he's in
that they all really in it look at that
oh was the SP oh they get inside
the Seance is starting said on the
drums cere he is tearing them drums
off DRS DRS there very he down with my
clan he down with my clan that's to be
your I love his energy though you can't
tell him that's not the hottest be right
now kind of like trying to do the
Running Man and beat on them Drums of
the The Running Man to the y de with
[Music]
it
boom they killed that they did that they
did their thing that was
cool they doing it a series X here we go
they doing it okay okay let's
quiet I need to see a sword of fear and
fury some fighting once they show the
release date that'll be
crazy M let's go oh oh yes of The Lost
Ones now pick up a sword now P Christ
any weapon at all please pick up a
weapon please Al have the stick at this
point yeah at this point throw a rock at
an enemy and please show
me at this point make a muscle do
something oh God that look crazy though
it it does but we know pick up this
there we go there go tons of rocks pick
up more rocks an arrow all right sword
okay come on the last don't cut the
trailer off after
this do not cut that trailer let's
go there let's go there we there we
go it better be more than
that it better be more than that there
we go weave we got the weave okay this
looking good man all
right okay let's go okay
yes keep it going you want the truth I
don't think they're going to show much
more than that give me more inside me
tell me to let go that is all the combat
we have the shadow will always see you
next year I know
right we know you look fire we know it
oh that look photo realistic that looks
photo realistic that look like a movie
right that a movie yeah straight
up back to the combat you you flood the
streets flood the streets Xbox the
combat flood the streets that's what I'm
talking about I like that
brutality keep the combat coming with
the straight all right that that might
be the best looking game Graphics God
hey that's right Grand Theft Auto is not
in that year let's
go the lane is clear the lane is clear I
see you
girl I see you girl I see you girl you
came outside right this time you came
outside right that's what I'm talking
about she didn't come out and stare at a
puddle it was we Ain got no we got 2024
we ain't got no month but y got that
combat thank you please oh my Lord let's
go that was crazy that was crazy that
was crazy good job she was like I told
y'all we had the combat all right what
an amazing new look at the gameplay and
world of Hell blade coming that look
pretty good I like the brutality the
stabbing in the neck
you know what I actually like the
most like weave of
the I don't know why that hit for me but
she had the sword and it's brutal oh by
the way Cog I just want to say to your
chat the other day when I was in here on
a Sunday when you guys were um going on
and I said go ner somebody said oh
Philly's going to
crush I'm talking to you guys you who
said that to me
upom what up now
l in the link yes sometimes in some
weird stuff we can't
explain Dam that hell blade was hard
body best oh best n what we got adct
what we got Story Only victim you and
said
Allan we might survive went on his own
ATT
allel Tim per oh admitted it he said
that was him that was I respect that
Philly fan I respect that good GG's
Brother G it's all good man it's all
good all F the game I respect that you
own it a lot of lot of Philly fans with
a ring Jo
us you know Philly they're good they're
okay they're good team they're te
they're all right they're okay they're
soft they're soft yes did s pick this
with me um did he Pi that you Alan W
Allan Wake I need to I need to keep
separating from
S I had to win something man got leave
well oh man I I I haven't played that so
I don't know
but it's not really a game I want to
play honestly like I'm not a of Remedy
but but hey it could have a I don't know
yeah um Alan way to hey other half of D
down KP wanted me to tell yall what's up
oh shout out to K I share this with the
whole narrative
teamers is I mean balers gate could
literally win every award far so I was
like this is the one I was like this is
the only shot people
really Spider-Man 2
didn't Nar over
weird all the wonderful actors here
tonight some of them Melanie uh Ila uh
mat and davage but the whole whole cast
wonderful watch that
comat that H music I got talkz he's got
to be going crazy story here tonight
later
oh they had the music on
my coming true FR music uh for songs
mhade just um it looks
good it like it's always a risk for you
to embrace it and understand mindblowing
man but Ninja Theory we knew they would
come with it I mean I'll be honest I
didn't think they were going to show up
I I was like three they save it for a
direct that means that shows me they're
ready they're ready this game is close
yeah it's
close and it it said captured on series
X right the beginning yes it did yes it
did yep they made sure yeah that that
help I'm good I notic I apologize by way
it was 30 frames yeah it look 30 it look
[Music]
30 that look phenomenal man oh my God
they did that sir this
is you may have recognized that
incredible Creator who built her own
independent studio in Tokyo and she
wanted to show you what she's been
working on before she's even signed it
with a publisher or a platform I said
come to this show just show it to the
audience and the fans first so that's
what we're going to do we're honored to
have her back at the game awards please
give a warm welcome welcome to akumi
Nakamura
[Applause]
energy of
stage
take amazing
[Music]
G super excited to be on this stage
again thank you
first first I want to say thank you to
the anen
artist and you thank you you you you all
you your support changing my life oh was
t on Titan was that yeah I saw that that
see like a tack on
dip down references that I would not
know about I have no idea I have no idea
she just looked like yeah I have no idea
ninja scroll you're supposed to be
watching that I thought you watch like
Gyver or something it was it was the
Scout uh thing
byee the fact that y'all knew exactly
what she was doing is mind-blowing to me
yeah I
know uhoh like to beat oh
oh oh
looks cool all right Sunset Overdrive
outside in Japan
Co-op ninja
overdrive like three people oh that's
o oh more
people five six emal all right got my
high on
you all right what type of game is it
you think I don't
know Inc tonight thank you akumi now
tonight it's not lost on me that all of
our game of year nominees are from Big
established franchises and well we all
love a big sequel it's important to use
a place like TGA to introduce you to
brand new worlds like what you just saw
with curay and like this
project private division private
division
a Titanic the
game
see SE of death yo look at the voice
effects what's this what's this bring
off the king we prayed
former we prayed for
[Music]
doe I'm not into this type of art to be
honest oh really I like I like these I'm
digging ite that Wicked creature right
there pretty sick it's
[Music]
different it's a what you say they
called party farty it's a little but
this is actually more double A they got
oh moon
oh that's oh this going to be that might
change things right there oh this going
to look already it looks good right
there the game play looks better than
the damn CG yeah that this going to be
fire cuz it it's criminal that ay was
never really nominated or won anything
his existence criminal this looks like
it could be a fun game
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah this is going to
be CRA oh man they got a little mature
tone with this oh they got the mature
I'm in Moon I'm in Moon Studio let's go
I see what we doing I see what we
doing I like the in-game graphics better
than the Cinematic I I like this touch
though it's like it feels very like I'm
reading a you know scripture on
something you know saying like you
reading a parable four scores back in
the day like I'm reading the back of a
serial box no rest for the wicked oh I
like that
name March learn more March 1st okay
multi get your back he that look fire no
rest for the wicked in action RPG from
Moon Studios and
more tonight during the game awards
viewers in the US can enter to win one
of 100 Lenovo Legion go gaming handhelds
a Windows 11 gaming PC in your hand head
to tg.com before the end of the show to
enter for your chance to win here's a
look at the legion go in action Legion
go have y'all mess with Y yet I know
y'all on the I'm I'm a rock Ally dude
but um I've heard I think solve is in it
oh got a detach controllers on it yeah
they got like the switch little
controller going on with
that see game passes all over the
discoveries are the ones you really
feel game pass the thrill of exploring
new
Worlds the rush of
Victory but there's still so much more
to discover interesting for C back
now PE I finally played it uh recently
for the first time and you know I don't
like Souls games cannot front that joint
is fire and I'm a person that hatte
Souls games me too yeah same I don't
know why I took a chance on it me
neither I just like let me try I mean it
was actually it was actually m m cuz he
went so hard you didn't try no no one
long with fire it's just I don't want to
be angry all day oh dude I love one of
my favorite games of the Year bro I far
as I feel you I just too old to be mad
at life angry day I just don't want to
be mad cuz I know I can't pass a certain
thing and then I get mad we need another
uh we need a part two of ghost we need
we need that
ghost Avatar
[Music]
adct I heard this is getting kind of mid
reviews is that true not very good like
something like that oh is out already
mhm yeah me the ways of the
na I'm not into the Avatar movie so I I
wasn't excited about
this what's the the game is like a
horizon kind of style game the
RDA that is don't know it's Ubisoft so I
figure it's probably an open
world there it is it's
like
Warriors Avatar frontiers of Pandora
available
now buy it now at
Target hold on hold up hold up this
H good day s you're just a
wh name when you go into battle I don't
know about these games bro a feel like
mobile energy feel like watching a
Nintendo
[Applause]
Direct yo I'm
done Discord gaming okay hey there
there's we have been saying
all down got to talk about some of
biggest games it's a pleasure not
feeling that last game cringe cringe
cring thank you thank you there you go
hey Jeff it's great to be here hello
everybody hey buddy thanks for uh coming
I looks like you're kind of wearing what
I'm wearing yeah it's like looking in a
mirror isn't it hey pretty
much he went all the way hwood I really
don't think oh
boy so gono what have you been
playing seriously what have you been
playing bro next year he's going to do
Hollywood Squares
watcho is buying everyone popcorn
tonight hey wait a minute all right that
was a good one you got me well played
Jeff yep the money at this point though
what have you been playing that epic
money well lots and lots of Tears in the
Kingdom what an incred game you know
that one mission where you follow the
cuckoo up a hill I lost track of how
many days I spent doing that the
objective is really you know just follow
the chicken you don't have to ask me
twice that's right you do love your
chicken so I gu that was your favorite
part what did you think of the ending oh
I never get past that cucko mission I
keep restarting to see if I can get a
slower
time well any otherlights this for actor
you kidding if you have the time hey you
guys got a minute no we actually don't
have a minute like to show you how many
this year's greatest games all revolve
around one time is up actually check
this out they need to play the
music wrap it up got the case for it
yeah that's quite a conspiracy you've
uncovered I know I know you probably
think I'm obsessed with Y somebody said
that the please laugh signs are flashing
in the back y interest oh no I mean yeah
I think we're all thinking that what are
we even talking about right now's what's
going on you think
Zelda game
this unbelievable all right here are the
nominees let's get back to it let's get
let's get back to it let's get let's get
we
could we got I think I had cocon in here
I think I had had cocoon yeah think I
hack
[Music]
AOL Pizza Tower what go with Best debut
indie game uh you went cocoon everyone
cocoon but I I want piz Tower oh you
went P to I don't know any of these so
I'm going to go viewfinder go viewfinder
I used to love you finder when I was a
kid remember that you
click on the camera and freaking disc
spins with great Gonzo thank you guys
and now to the task at hand the game
award goes
to ah cocoon cocon just beat it uh last
week I don't like it fantastic game wow
well I was looking for all the old
people becoming young young again and
they weren't there it's funny you're
ridiculous you are ridicul ridiculous
shout out to Kon you're still ahead by
one I know barely I need that two space
lead just in
case shout to Kon originally down with
the play dead team went solo did they
thing thank you so much uh the team from
geometric didn't make it out tonight uh
but they wanted us to pass along their
thanks played and voted for cocoon for
cocon Andi
mads and everyone at the team at
geometric thank you so much for being
such a wonderful partner on this game
why couldn't they make it their own game
got an award L I think they I think they
team also wanted Tok they were honored
to be nominated all in this got them
boys out there man thank y fly them boys
out there take take the Gonzo money and
fly it to
Des might be another reason like that
might be another reason I'm being I'm
being complet of 2023 but which title
are you most most excited to see Go
Mobile in 2024 Google Play will be
awarding the most anticipated tile what
title you want
mobile V I want to see now it's time for
our next I want to see Spider-Man 2 Go
Mobile what is this oh it already is
with the portal oh I see Shinobi in the
back they already won I saw a real life
arcade Shinobi in the back
though yeah you see it in the backi oh I
got that cuz I I literally own
oh you have that yes that's the board I
have that's literally the the whole
stand up upright
unit do you have the original or like
original I bought it from a Texas uh
arcade distributor off of eBay back in
the day had
it my mom was like when are you yeah
from Texas it was an old arcade that
going to grow up really I know she's
like when are you going to grow up and
when are you getting this out of this
house cuz you don't live you're like
never I'm like I I I'll get it
eventually
oh Sega oh this super game this is super
game shobi I see what's going
on what we doing Sega we doing Cloud
maybe this what Peter Moore this is what
um Sarah and them was teasing what we
doing all the classics Blue Area y this
is this the
thing let's go what we
doing there Gauntlet is that Gauntlet
new energy so we get to play all the s
crazy t
yeah this is all new stuff though
it's okay and more now in
development well what what's the how
y'all doing it powerful next level is it
Cloud streaming Tik Tok YouTube golden a
that's right we do it though how do we
get it I love the
energy give me the
deeps oh yeah now typically a world
premiere reveals one game but leave it
to Sega to announce five new games in
one trailer so many memories for all of
us many brand new games in development
and set for release over the next s
years thanks to Sega for that truly
incredible announcement we accessing it
though well this next trailer might be
something Dragon B waiting to hear about
looks like what we doing game we've been
hearing about for a while upset B down
Nam what they upset there's like I can't
believe that you're rushing people off
the stage but you're letting mu be on
the stage yeah oh here this is dip down
an attic let's go what's the new one oh
this is the what's this
shis don't don't Kar don't do that k k
that's that's that's what that was right
kab
slander this Goan which one is this
that's Goku and Vegeta okay
okay bro watch that's that's trunks
that's now you no I I want to be on
point with
y'all this this is this this is it I'm
in I'm in that's tail whip right there
tail whip devastating tail
whip oh that's white that's that's
that's his ultimate level with his hair
is golden right y That's yellow hair
good bro you want to be hey you want to
play him fighter I think it was I think
it was this I've been y'all I'm I'm down
with the L it's another head fighter
fighter behavior in the oh Behavior I
was trying to watch but I couldn't get
past all the
messiness
did you see I trying to relate to the
game it's that uh the dead by daylight
game whatever's down there Byer they're
making a game in the dead by daylight
world in the world oh my son don't like
this he likes that
[Music]
daylight boy got bodies on
there
song but I know I
won't song is
[Music]
fire
there why are they going in there like
that like I know right yeah what reason
would you have
go in that dark scary place let's go
bloody hooks on the
wall oh no y to investigate I'm he got
that whatever it is he owns
that and don't run walk away from that
because you're going to trip if you run
you know those movies G in the Frank
Stone just walk away cinematic
experience from the those are them
joints though those be them
joints that by daylight that's right two
huge names in the horror genre dead by
daylight and super games are coming
together for a brand new single player
experience the casting of Frank Stone
now tonight we're showing you lots of
new worlds but now it's time to return
to a world we haven't seen in quite some
time maybe we don't want to see it damn
father starting to look like that I
don't
[Music]
know who this dip what's this why you
coming at
me this any Anime World this anime this
is you you supposed to know the all the
history of this I don't know who there
she goes oh this this he already know
tails game is this Tales yeah this which
RPG is this sh MIM May this is what ifon
say this is tell with squ oh this adct
all add you know this this Tactic six
what's
this oh my God this is addict all the
way looks
fire I can't wait he quiet he focused it
too kind of cool though wait for
this I've been all my life see what new
Mana Secret of
Mana I know I know about
Mana you know about Mana about Mana that
that's a that's my
generation yep Secret of Mana I remember
that game oh never played it never
visions of man yeah it's like success
you car you know this it was old it was
old it was old enough for my demographic
to
know coming out for Xbox it's coming for
Xbox said Xbox logo yeah at the top it
said Xbox okay oh co techmo it is that
Time Marches to the beat of a drum go is
this the rise of the Ronin this is all
this who's that who's that it's me me
it's all me looks real good he said he
dis rced his master and the ninjas are
here I know the know the plot huh I know
the plot I know I know it all that I
love that haircut when they team ninja
ninja head like that keep that little
strip in the middle amazing is that time
la
what even if we are up go talk ain't
going crazy right now facts you besides
the Muppet thing this has been a good
video so far yes this game I I've been
hype on this game since I saw yeah this
is
fire especially after playing W long bro
like I'm
ready let's do this
together see this is more action right
as opposed to
ssy no I I I would say it's still the
same cuz it seems very cinematic like
being Sony energy alter this look
definition
Soul
ofat such a oh
no this look fire though that long it
was a good game I know I I know you you
beat all listen all he had to tell me
was that name lu bo and I have respect
for that game I heard he was screaming
that man
name yeah R the Ronin it's a good one
nice time exclusive fire that's a good
pallet cleanser right there after you
seen all that trash oh they got Mass
ninja so which of you will do the deed
that's Mass
face for oh Mar early we let all three
months all right that's a nice one I
like that that's rise of the Ronin
coming to Playstation in 2024 now it is
time to announce winners in a number
ofed
best damn I forgot what I pick I think I
pick high
five Dead Island ghost Runner two high
five rush
and and gameward goes to armore let's go
wow did it best action game
congratulations best art Direction
though the nominees for
best
Rush lies of Super Mario
Brothers of theing I don't know why
super mar
there wow won AR dire I don't think none
of us got that
Oneil mode and snaps and the
go resent anybody pi I don't think
anybody it all right
cool hell kitty is
Adventure
hello you remember I don't think weile
we I'm all H goes
to
honai
KY me
just
gods
some of our biggest game announcements
are still to come but right now we'd
like you to meet one
of Best debut indie game was also part
of the newly inducted future class
presented by
old my name is ABI in India when I grew
up I had a very early interest in games
when I got to Canada at the age of 12 it
was a whole new world for me for many
South Asian families food is is not just
a thing to cook but also a
way you you went against the grand you
did it that your heart that tells the
story
of Canada in the late 1980s it's a story
about love loss and family best the more
local you are the more International you
become
everyone was high Rush besides King he
pck armor C that was his heart pick so
King if he would have picked armored
Core right there he would have he would
have got
that te de Zen zp on a
graphics oh you know what's funny v r AR
everyone's heart was Resident Evil and
we didn't pick it I know cuz I was like
Resident Evil normally wins those Awards
I was like I know cuz I thought the
other games were good but yeah Resident
Evil
man Panda she didn't realize I had two
account still stub on this one salute
pandas good to see you in
we want
you are you what was best art
Direction Alan Wake your your heart was
Alan Wake
too I'm really surprised that balder's
gate wasn't in best art
Direction yes Bal gate legit
e what is this you hurt the children out
multiplay grind wait do we have to grind
the children
what up man welcome in okay now we sit
down very comy bag it's so flimsy to way
some of these awards are thrown out
yeah minutes yeah people are really
upset over that on yeah I've always had
that Muppet that Muppet stuff it wasn't
even funny it wasn't even funny it
wasn't necessary that I've always said
that I do not like developers winning
Awards off screen rush through and it's
just like I agree they could a lot of
the fluff bro the even if you're going
to say that you don't have time for all
of them fine but you could have
eliminated Gonzo you know what I mean
like that could have been a
segment gone chicken could have left we
just want want this approved this is all
Oscars we love it we just
wanted chat they've been messaging this
whole time in the chat what they
say in the chat they've been messaging
what the whole time they' been in the in
in uh the I chat what they been saying
uh said let's
go you need to focus back on work
welcome back to the game awards and are
you ready it is time to get a world
premiere from one of our industry's
greatest creators he's been a huge
supporter of the game award since the
very
beginning look at his face look at his
face look at his face update with you
he's in love here it is yeaha either the
death stranded or the Xbox Drake saw he
was he gave you them smoldering
eyesa game every time he talks
about Z Fox the jaing crab and the Mad
whale and started vending and quacking
sopia Lis vending and quacking the
hungry purple dinosaur ate the kind Z
and the Mad whale and started vending
and
cracking M new IP that was disturbing a
little bit this is very disturbing but
look at the graphics
dinosaurs sing Fox
to started ring
anding
this is the definition of Kojima yeah
it's so out there is she
good is she good I don't think she good
bro I don't think she good right
now oh she startled me I'm yeah I I
don't like this already o yo the name of
the game is o oh man overdose o for all
the players and the screamers oh it's
the X
the Xbox J it's called o y'all we o on
this oh we G to get promotion the Xbox
tax is out now y'all we got kajima
behind it we got Jeff we good we good
now I'm o I'm o be good man the bag was
paid Kaja going come out Kaja going to
come out we o d we get all the mark G
developer
behind let's get
it
all that Xbox Blazer all that they he
well funded the heaven that boy got a
lion Crest on his all his
braer what is that oh he got his logo in
Platinum oh yeah sh check C thank you
Jeff Che C
quick
Manch
most overrated
develop relax you show respect to
the respect to the king I'm really glad
to be at the 10th this is the l l king
L and this title will Fe Main
Roop Hunter schaer and okay I think we
all want to more yes we want to know
more yes what type of game is this
please he don't even
know
rolling so Microsoft gave us mad bread
you don't even understand what we us
whatever want SP
it you see this jacket think the game is
whatever I tell you it's going to
be say there's rocks to be thrown this
rock to be
thr this game's going to be whack but
you guys are
you it he say I don't care what I do you
going love it y you going love
it thank you for the always challenge
things groundbreaking things and that's
my kind of rule uh but this one um with
uh help of XO Xbox game studios and
using their uh cloud gaming technology
um I'm kind of doing this uh together
but it's it's really to make immersive
and also something that never no one has
seen before is what I'm trying to do and
it is a get T wrong but it's at the same
time a movie but at the same time a new
form of media do something never seen
before well we can't wait to learn more
about what
you're Kima jacket is o oh Phil runs on
stage oh no no it come Phil that's not
fa n that's not fail them shoes are too
big welcome oh Jordan oh the budget is
crazy oh Xbox got the whole budget
Down
music it's o
d
deep they got a a Ron and all that
what's up how's it
going oh my God Jordan welcome to the
game awards what a fun surprise I know
you're a big fan of hide's games right a
huge fan of hide this man is an
that and uh I I can just I can say from
the first moment I played Metal Gear
Solid 2 knew it okay that's a good game
though I knew I was
experiencing of an arti listen who craft
Just Hits different checks always
command and he's been an inspiration to
me and the opportunity to collaborate
with him is truly incredible in my films
I'm always trying to to maximize the
immersion put the audience into the main
character's
shoes Deo is the master of this and he
does it Jeff sh it ah head I want to
hear nothing about no Xbox tax at all
ever again and what he's cooking up here
is utterly terrified and I am absolutely
honored to be collaborating with right
the checks are
cleared you know understood everything
just making people talk for him at this
let's see how collaboration
go we got y look K in the chat throw the
PS5 away now your P now
you
sleep
what he say what he say what he say well
Jordan is one of those genius and I've
been a big fan of him and when I met him
I felt like we were friends from the
past we get on very well we like things
that we both like and we're really happy
and we wanted toate and this time um
well Jordan I I grew up watching movies
and I'm a game creator now Jordan grew
up playing games and he's a movie
director now so this two collaboration
will be really awesome so that's why I
wanted to do something together with
Jordan so he's making a movie game for
Xbox Xbox that's it it's like he's
always idolized movies he makes he's Us
Xbox to work
with qur the time look at the time
budget I don't want to hear anything
about
no whole show B
hijacked
yeah this is Xbox takeover take
over what to me y want to do memes on my
face last
year someone say Xbox tax refunds y'all
got refund we we getting a refund
now so uh what I could say right now is
that I'm kind of um um it's not just
Jordan I have other uh creative
collaborate Partners uh with me on board
on this project I can't really uh say we
got now but they I tell you they are the
legends they're going to be and actually
call them thebox hir the Avengers of
everybody to act in in studio that's it
it's over closed for now so no more
special test but it's going to be
amazing what if the show is just they
keep bringing out more people that's
working on the game through that door
what if there's no more game awards and
they keep bringing more dudes that's
working on the game what they do is they
start just the people that
come Kima Jordan Peele thank you so much
guys you notic no music played over him
or music in love with
that soart they know what they doing
look at
that play chess out here you play a
chess baby this is a
Jurassic Spar no
expense looks like it yeah it sounds
like it I wanted to
show working with mention yeah app
that's that's that's your people oh wait
is
this Jurassic par game oh it would be
kind of cool part game though like
Uncharted St this is Dr Maya Joshi I've
been left behind on East
new who's Mak Phil Dominus Maximus aelia
Spencer this looks like uh like a dead
by daylight kind of game yeah we just
get to be a
dinosaur that' be
crazy graic Co graffic oh she the whole
little thing oh no she ain't doing it so
Xbox had hellblade
too
kajima that's
crazy
[Music]
yeah is anyone
there
[Music]
SP say Miranda Sanchez you they
stupid water
oh oh
she
[Music]
game
footage it's kind of like an alien
isolation fil
[Music]
survival
oh now for you you guys can play that
that's for you you guys please welcome
Grammy Award winning producer zed
z
oh bade he probably one of ke's favorite
producers I'm honored to be here tonight
to present the award for
best sound isn't overlooked
but game development it's what brings
games to life creating the immersive
worlds we love to explore it's the Eerie
noises deep in the forest the echos
inside or the satisfied
sound think
this year we've seen some
Inc they might get soundtra but not this
but we'll see here are the nominees
maybe dead space cuz space Alan Wake
might toot of and you said Alan Wake
might get it our heart was high five
rush and solving King said their heart
was dead space so what was my pick your
pick was high five we all said high oh
God I don't like remakes being put oh
yeah I hate remakes you know I feel
that's just you remix somebody
verse don't get me wrong I no for no at
all REM I mean no they should have their
own category REM
Rems yes let's go with Janis where's my
man where's my man let's go he got let's
go that's my man what happen go stand up
let's go t What happen let's go it I
think we the rebate checks came in y'all
the rebate checks came in I'm telling
y'all it's over y can't run with that
narrative uh thank you so
much proud of man
came through in the real he pulled up in
the real too right ad mhm pulled up to
talk to us quick translation thank you
for this amazing award it's so glad that
the work that the team has done together
recognized here thank you to everyone
who supported this project and for
myself thank you to our family friends
Partners
pets Mt M and all the players out there
don't forget um for going with this
ridiculous project of all to the team of
Tango for taking such a wild idea and
making it a reality Tango let's get it
so proud of him
let's look at all the security yeah they
like yeah get make sure make sure they
good on the
space expanding into a fullon platform
with tons of Battle Royale earlier today
Lego fortnite launched and on Saturday
the music game fortnite Festival
tomorrow though the team at psionics
behind rocket League delivers rocket
racing here your
that PA is so
foul don't be a grumpy old man pause let
the kids have some oh they can have it
already they can keep it they can keep
it they can keep this your
PA I'm good man but we going to get our
Co-op rocket RAC you know you not going
to do this fire up some
Ballers when it gets on game pass
tonight this is the epitome of a hey
guys game hey hey guys welcome back to
the channel guys today I'm going to show
you some rocket racing yes yes this is
the so hey guys energy very
bubbly and yous crazy I'm clowning this
is going to do so well
it's fortnite is the live service of the
generation there going be a 2our for
this as well oh yeah going BL the world
true Tim I I I don't care for racing
yeah I used to I used to like him back
in the day back in the day Midnight Club
oh rocket racing interesting so it's oh
find it in fortnite wow they got they
got so many dimensions to fortnite it's
it's insane
captured on PC
to uhoh there you go this is C this
feels very Cog like is this black uh
what it called the
the Wong or don't you do that don't you
say that's W oh don't you do that yeah I
think it is well say it's black myth W
black myth that's what I was right here
don't you don't you say I think I think
that's what it is uhoh oh you must Ste
the
stroke maybe yeah maybe it is
yep it is game science game sence what
did we get the
platforms I tell you right now though if
XBox stole a a Game Pass package that'll
be crazy then why is there always
suffering and why do the
winus game looks
unreal
yo it's one of those games I've been
waiting for fors the world with blood GR
lotuses in it man this is a stunning
game is your destiny I would say this is
probably the only G I feel like really
looks like next gen but here's the yeah
you're
right but if it doesn't get like a hard
release date I know cuz we seen it a few
times now I know I don't I don't think
it exist for look at that looks
incredible Jesus surely know how to
name signs are the mythology is just
insane
all in glory 30
frames say captur on
PC will
as U
game me what justifies your
[Music]
superiority damn look it's tearing him
up
yo adct I'll be Shing you on during
those boss fights
[Music]
[Applause]
so
Jesus it's at the point like what is
this game not
doing like like it's
everything
yo they got the attack on Titans attack
on
titans black myth all right we doing
what we do when is it coming Game Pass
August oh we got a hard date hard date
finally it's real yes it's real it's
real Xbox series X and S and S glorious
B Green Lantern The Flash what's this
Suicide Squad friends are slaughtering
the people to protect no than no people
are liking it though I heard oh a lot of
people I know don't like it at
alln Earth down for
me it's not going to do well how do I
stop this you have to kill us Diana we
have to die to save the world we can
work with
that it's sad because I don't want to
see a game fail
but playing Gill you think you're a team
now you think you can stop us thought
you'd
[Music]
never this is is not
you don't
like no the people that I know that are
playing play the
aling to all these girlfriends are just
crazy I heard some people that actually
liked it that's all surprised too it
look kind of
crazy I play it though just watch I a
playing m yet what's the plan time for
us bad guys to save the
world
[Music]
look how somebody said look how they
Mass it my boy come on nend out anyone
who has played it will change their
opinion that's what I've been hearing
too Suicide
Squad everybody know played it like
dropped tonight for those of you
watching on Twitch but I understand
you've also got some other news for
Warframe FL oh Warframe Flame yeah we
for Warframe so you know 10 years for
you we assumed we'd get a senior's
discount of sometime just cuz our game
is probably the oldest game here maybe
but yeah we have keep going strong I
know it's because our community is so
awesome and we are going to be showing
you the release date for our next major
update for Warframe so we do have a
trailer Warframe players around the
world quite exciting yeah I mean it's
been an incredible ride 10 years
incredible developers or Community just
supporting us along the way so if you're
a Warframe fan and watching we love you
and thank you so much and I hope you
enjoy the next update Whispers in the
walls oh yeah thanks for having us back
too dev's at home we love you guys all
right thanks guys let's take a look
let's take a look for Generations you've
slept no
purpose no call to wake you great but
now Warframe you have changed everything
I play Warframe for like 5 minutes and
just jump back to fortnite the lless eye
has you the tenno the
Teno very loyal
Community go to Lords of gaming down
there my man flame will give you all the
Warframe coverage you need every week he
goes hard in the paint and we going to
see an article for this for
sure D all right all right that's
pretty
play
War father Gucci you got to
relax so yo he said we have Destiny at
home yo y'all got to
relax the slander is real that's wild
slanderous oh that look crazy it is Sony
did
kill oh we fighting in the trains now oh
I know about this I know about this
flame put me on to this flame put me on
to this this is
crazy new expansion Whispers In The
Wall somebody said great value Destiny I
cannot with y'all there is so
D you the surpr I used to play it back
day there Lots coming but while you're
here superame awards.com de
chance to win a trip for to the brand
new Super Nintendo World at Universal
Studios Hollywood here's a
look they just jump right in they not
even pissed about the floor or nothing
of course ready for a new way to play oh
this is the real Amusement part world of
Super Mario yeah brought to life like
never before already already know
Nintendo you got your ticket
L
met I know yall there I know y go this
is y people St y That's signing
up yep that's them oh Starfield I know
that don't you do it don't you give me
the shattered expansion
information don't you give me shattered
space what we doing
Starfield okay we just talking we just
talking we just talking numbers talking
what we doing out
[Music]
here we
[Applause]
[Music]
doing we just flexing we just we just
showing them that we well we just
flexing sh to resume real fast yeah he
like stop hating look at our numbers 12
million stop hate look at the numbers
get out your feelings look at all those
that's all this is this is get out your
feelings
we congratulate for wi yes yes we conat
we were supposed to be here we just want
to let Resident Evil 4 know what time it
was and who the fans
like thank you Starfield do it indirect
I Know What You Did Starfield I know
what you did I like that I like that
energy to the living death to the dead
we have sworn to protect the Liv
lingering death keep the Incarnate and
the invisible separate to bring looks
like Diablo yeah this feel like Diablo
that grip on this world is broken what
you
doing you like me being messy on that
one I had to y'all that's for my
Starfield game yall know what time it
is what's
this o what's this death to the
dead a whole lot of nothing right
now to the dead honoring
my sacrificing the Liv to bring me back
oh oh this game I remember seeing the
trailer for this game this game I think
or bring me
back but don't leave me
[Music]
like it you don't look
B banish somebody said banish your Mac
OG banish okay this is bishers yeah
bishers ghost of the new Eden 911 this
call is being recorded what is your
emergency I I need the police you know
how the police away I'm
[Music]
sorry you ready wait a minute who the
what's this what's this down right is
down look kind of
crazy look kind of crazy got to get you
look out
[Music]
ready officer is down and we need back
up let's go get back can still make it
out of this what is this
goft game
I don't
know very Ubisoft UB so are you ready
those hands do Ready or Not Ready or Not
little PC JW all right all right oh yeah
that game's already out it's already out
all the time okay okay so what is it
like tactical what it BG says this it's
it's
his the best thing he's going to get
close to so
okay AG of Empires Call of Duty war zone
mobile little nightmares and Tom
Clancy's Rainbow 6 are just some of the
big titles coming to Mobile in 2024 head
to the game awards on Twitch to vote for
which title you want to win Google
Play's own play more award now please
welcome last year's winner of games for
impact for the game as which is on March
7th and for pre-order tonight aming team
director car Marshall love them so proud
when they game surprised me that game so
good shout out to adct for for listening
and and doing the stream you know what
I'm say lady
adct b everyone winning last year was
definitely of my 22 years in the
industry games for impact is one of the
most important categories at the game
awards the games nominated this year
offer unique and nuanced perspectives on
topics that concern us all from the
climate crisis to cultural diversity
they broaden our Horizons Foster empathy
and connect us as humans in a world torn
apart by divisions and intolerance this
is one of the most essential powers of
our medium here are the outstanding
nominees shout out to my man Luke manard
though he should have been here he got
light in the darkness on the Holocaust I
should have been there too shout out to
my May L says a traveler will reunite
the people's oh this is the one I like
goodby Volcano High which what did we
vote um adct um bbo you and King and me
and S set a space for the uh Unbound
yeah you guy said that and me and him
said a space okay you and D me and Saul
oh no too oh
no Chia Chia nobody P Chia right oh but
my song So heart pick
heart follow your heart man I follow
your heart is that the do for
PlayStation yeah yeah salute yo
Che thank you always like this energy I
accept this a on behalf of yeah I like
him I like his energy always PlayStation
to me you know I mean co-founder our I'd
like to thank our family for your trust
and amb believable Talent KLA and Sony
for believing in this crazy
project and the entire population of New
calonia who championed and embraced
cheer all along thank you
[Applause]
Mery how we share games on PlayStation
oh yeah that bro that was a killer blow
love love that guy
hello what we doing what we doing out
here I'm abak I'm mainly known for my
acting work in Raised by Wolves did he
say he was raised by W Orin and his his
work by race shout out to my tribes
shout to my shout out to the king I was
like that's badass bro this Bo's a kid
out here he's a kid out here sorry now
this is this is crazy trip is
ill I mean I I remember watching the
game awards when I was younger of being
up here and now was
like
look I've I've Loved games all my life
uh I mean I played them all my life man
from Kingdom Hearts Gary's
Mod Golden
Sun and it it it started with my dad
right he got me into them he understood
you know that games are an art form you
know it's a great space to enjoy and
escape from the reality of the world and
he passed away a while back and I'll
tell you what I'm still figuring it
out but four years ago I decided that I
needed to try and process my grief in a
way that felt true to me and him so I
took the biggest risks of my life and
through everything that I had in making
a game a piece of art that honored him
and O to the people we have loved and
lost
so so the reason I'm here tonight is
because with the love and support of a
lot of people here I'm going to take
another big risk and I'm going to show
you what we've been building no I'm
going to offer you this game a game from
my old man I hope you like it all right
all right all right
brother yeah original every Story begins
at the end of
another each story carries with it the
Echoes of those that came before
my Baba my father your story was
snatched away too
soon my name is Zao a shaman of
Kera here I seek my father
jutan okay okay that look Prett good all
right
bro we might be in all right
or me right to about yeah and we going
for the all right all right now I got to
rep the tribes man got to rep for the
people for the
culture
[Music]
okay oh we got ice powers okay okay we
got
bosses right holdie I'm
in I cannot stop I will not
stop konga god of death
kunga god of death come to
me pretty sick show me you
are s let's go all right shout out to
the king all right Tails kette all right
all right all
right I'm with it I'm with that yeah I'm
with that
[Music]
too uh so ad what's the vibe right now
I'm feeling like maybe I'm biased
I'm feeling like this show is kind of
dope so
far yeah it's a good
[Music]
show life Strange
Life
D their best game was the original
strange the original yeah the original
was though so
good I remember that scene on the roof
and if you wasn't paying attention the
whole girl you oh that was real yeah
that was real that game tested you I
seen the game test me with it FLW early
to see if I was paying attention
mhm it's been 27 years y'all what's
going on why
now because oh I'm in on
this
promise they always had the great good
narratives in G that was L record BR New
World from the development team behind
life is strange now we have a world
premier new look at a game based on an
ongoing franchise of 18 years with over
850 million users worldwide this
entirely inen engine trailer shows off
the blend between cartoon 3D graphics
with hardcore action this is the first
Berserker
[Applause]
Berserker nope dnf or
dnf
finally I found
you trampled by the one who
trusted a band from your
king you thought you were a
hero okay likeing style
okay animation is tight
you old man look we got we got maturity
on this got blood we got blood come on
for
us oh we got we got curb stops this No
Ordinary
Ghost oh I like the style though weird
mix it's a weird mix they got SE energy
going ad how we
feeling look cool so
s it's definitely
Souls
yeah look
good I don't mind soul when they have
like story it's the first Berserker
Kazan I like when they try to put story
in looks good right all right now it's
time for our first performance by the
game
awards
ready a little bit of a Twist they're
about to play music from an upcoming
game that no one has heard that's a b
statement and this is a special one it's
written by one of the greatest video
game composers of all time the legendary
yeah I love his
work here is the game awards Orchestra
by Lauren B with lead vocals from Lauren
alred debuting the theme song from Final
Fantasy
7 we in they got us yeah they got us
they got us we got a listen now
damn I'm kind of like worried to play
this out loud
like sing along guys if you they got the
game playay look they got the game for
the back the game play come on this what
you wanted oh no bro I'm I'm there for
this game for sure I love Final Fantasy
my girl is all over this game I'm just
saying I'm I'm trying to give it some
quiet moments here for for the chat to
sing along you know the words are on the
screen go ahead and sing if you you know
it the pass for me is the pass for
me let's get it y'all put your hands
together God damn
it clap your stop your feet Dam it here
you go here you go go did somebody say
this was
trash how dare you slander Final Fantasy
7 Zack and and the timelines is crazy I
don't know what's happening I've never
been into Final Fantasy unfortunately
how dare you just
skip
this is dare you amaz how dare you they
don't the same thing how dare you this
is the birth of your beloved
anime this you pay respect EV you know I
should put you in
class got to put you in wee class right
now this
is I I know you guys played Final
Fantasy 16 right I I just don't know why
they didn't go with the type of combat
that you know Final Fantasy 7 went with
you know getting the
I I prefer this way more the classic
style I got
[Music]
you I'm happy for the people who are
happy about that that's what somebody
don't lik I'm happy for
yall like is so rebirth is so important
we already started like doing the the
show the after it comes
out oh wow focusing on who's coming
on that's fun that's how ridiculous we
are in our calender it literally says
the the Final Fantasy rebirth show
straight up take over when does that
drop 28th of February February and
you're already planning this after show
damn like six months at a time of the
shows this is great for y I'm happy for
y'all that's right
yo they got the security tight in the
front you see the ropes absolutely
beautiful song from Final Fantasy 7
rebirth which is nominated for most
anticipated game tonight thank you to
Lauren alred and Maestro Lauren Bal and
the game awards Orchestra they will be
back later to pay tribute to our game of
the year
nominees but that's not all we have
tonight for Final Fantasy fans oh this
is not for me another trailer REM
rebirth what we've done that's set in
stone
or so they'll tell you de because the
fut has the power what's this what's
this uhoh has his hands
up it going crazy y add it going crazy
Buster
swords out there somewhere about to get
M Apex oh Apex Legends in Final Fantasy
that's what I saying
crossover
uhoh fortnite done for adct now yeah
they coming for fortnite anything about
Apex I don't even play it but I knew
that was Apex for say Apex we tired of
y'all fortnite we tired you going come
over here y going
play I don't know if that's going to
change on January 9th and that dra byan
himself thank you so much for that
incredible announcement now it's time to
announce the winners of a fewer award
speed through award jury in the category
best i w 2 balers Gate 3 Final Fantasy
16 High rush and The Legend of Zelda of
the and the game award goes
to anybody that I'm looking for
congratulations the nominees for best
G
the the I think I forgot what I picked
and the gameward goes to oh [__]
[Applause]
day the best the best fight in the
community
support all
day
congratulations all right fighting your
best fighting game I know what
ibat going Nickelodeon
allar
stre
figh and the game award this year goes
to I know I picked that no love for
Killer Instinct all
right
anticipated Nomes this year Final
Fantasy we said for anticipated game I'm
going to go
withes love to win my heart but I don't
think
it's what we pick and the game award
this year goes to Fantasy 7 I think we
pick that right most anticipated gations
Square yeah I think we all final months
since the release ofai star winner
tonight best mobile
game set for
Interac exclusive SC music SC music
Final Fantasy W it Final Fantasy okay
scoring music yeah Final Fantasy 16
solving King said 16 he took did he take
the lead he took the lead that think
that means he's the
lead take knees you got to get the ship
bro your shows are empty right now
oh this is bad this is bathroom break
right here I'll be back yo what is she
doing all right so hold up real quick
I'm going to start getting rid of some
of these we did most
anticipated it's taking too long to look
for this stuff your best multiplayer
memories no no best adapation no best
sports in racing no no no best Sim
strategy no we did best family yes mhm
we did best
fighting we did did we do RPG no no we
did best action we didn't do best action
adventure we did best VR and AR best
mobile
mhm this looks cool though Best
debut and we did they did best
independent game day right just now see
stars yes who picked that who Okay best
support Community Support we did did
they just do that one yeah yeah that
Destiny 2 so I my 18yearold son talk to
my 18y old what Community Support dip
down I'm sorry it was B gate B gate who
pck
that me and you are tonight for best
mobile gam Monster Hunter now is theob
second
in the real world and tonight have a
special iname event going on 18-year-old
son who plays all those kind of games
like Apex fortnite all that stuff he
said
that monster
H got an exclusive new look at the new
Fallout
series yes yes n we
did SC music
there's still a few rewards left here's
the thing all right first off let me let
me turn this down this is a little
r they they just like SP speed read like
eight Awards and we've seen the same
commercial four times Muppets
like add Revenue brother I feel you on
that but it just it feels like a slap in
the face like oh yeah I'm with you I'm
I'm I'm with you
four times now that's
EP get him get him get him d new
mop the way addict served that up though
was a perfect yo we're tied Cog oh for
first no for a
second I was devastated that was
completely which means I can finish last
now s is uh number one
right by two points oh no it's only
one me and you have uh nine and he's got
10 mhm okay King has seven oh gosh all
right I'm going try to Quick bathroom
same
all right skola buns I'm going to the
bathroom
too God that looks
trash
somebody said it will sell hundreds I
love
that what I miss what I
miss
bones everybody dipped
out everybody dipped out on the skull
Bon they should have canceled SK bones
there's no hype uh oh the studio that
won best game Direction in 20121 is but
that's the uh oh where y'all at from the
studio that put this Arcane this is it
[Music]
oh is Curr all C
[Applause]
re turn that [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
up
look who's in that seat
mhm relax man I don't
[Music]
bite oh yeah it's true it's true y'all
it's real it's real y'all fck tight
now that beat heavy night's just getting
started it's real
y'all that be okay different art style
different art style there
youa from Arcane Leon and Bill Rosman
from Marvel to tell us how did this come
together guys well Jeff let me tell you
the secret superpower of Marvel games is
our constant focused on bringing
together world class Talent with the fan
favorite characters that they love now
we are huge fans of arcan Leon not only
because of the story Rich games they
create with Innovative gameplay but
because of their authentic passion
that's why on blad's 50th Anniversary we
are so honored to announce this true
Marvel team up yes and uh after dishonor
and death loop our first order of
business was to make another very Arcane
game but with a title that is easier to
say in a French accent and uh when we
had you know when Sebastian miton and I
had an opportunity to chat with Marvel
said okay let's really challenge them
let's present our wildest take on a
superhero that we both they didn't bring
up red and we ate it up this the 18 me
the
Arcane tradar trench this Leon and I
mean think about it it's it's a
mature single player where you get to
play blade your way for True Believers
it's a dream come true true very excited
to learn more uh ding why this character
well he's the day walker uh Eric Brooks
is halfman half vampire Torn Between the
warm Society of the living and the
rushing power of the undead and uh as a
kid of mixed Origins his dual Heritage
resonated with me so yes it is a dream
to be making a game about blade in Paris
my hometown you
know he ready he ready he
ready he ready
you can't even dress like blade if my
hometown was came blade outfit came with
and we shared it with bloodthirsty
Invaders that come out as soon as the
sun goes
down anything else you could tell us
about the game I know it's pretty early
right uh I can tell you one thing okay
uh the entire team at Arcane Leon is you
know pouring so much love into this
immersive third
person third person I like
let us cook and
voila I like
that was worried because it was our I
thought it be first person as well y I
thought it would be first person as well
that's
big
got style though art style but it I
don't care I know I
know you know what I care
about BL pop culture IP on Xbox that's
what I'm talking fact you can go back to
2017 2018 I was asking for blade from
Xbox on RDX I wanted to Blade hey I just
want to say a big thank you to everyone
who watched Twisted Metal on peacock
that was a good show that was a good
show in the chat
yeah up here okay what about that tax
yeah I don't know man I got my rebate
check okay all right I know I say a lot
of different things you can't scream
them
all y I'm entertain y' I'm now no one
knows
this everybody else J because of you was
right you was right I thought they was
you push him back on that hardcore cuz I
don't want to get I didn't want to get
my heart broken if it's too much you
know I'm
[Applause]
saying everybody get your motor cuz
you're going on another ride with John
so you said last us
of they said we can't hear they said
they can't hear look oh they can't hear
them oh cuz we talking too much sorry
don't you at me I love you
more I love
you what is wrong with
y'all my gu is
H stop it you okay love you too I see
you I
see shut up okay
today the best games are like living
universes constantly expanding with new
content and
challenges right and that's what this
award for best ongoing game
recognizes games that continue to
deliver fresh experiences for their
loyal
communities fortnite we
also fortnite Forte never win but this
might be the year epic bag behind the
show listen listen
about this
year ongo game live service why is that
even in here live service last game last
Serv you didn't know every year you pick
up it you didn't know
m fortnite is over there's that game I
ever won an award at the game award
besid impact let's go baby we all said
fortnite play my heart was 14 I get so
many cool points with my son's for this
oh yeah fortnite it's def what he say
his sons it's fortnite fortnite you got
to get
this shut up can he
stop 277 I'm about to run out no I
thought he was just joking
yo
why that's a different type of ta y I'm
sorry to tell you song punk I just love
oh God
how the hell
is what a journey about to say yo he a
snitch he got somebody inside video
games are awesome an incredible
moment to 1.5 to 2.0
inan I love y'all Ain no
I'm stories basically now if you would
said best expansion you know the world
being
just being
fun this is exting team we accept this
on behalf of hundreds of people who put
their hearts in souls in it please sasco
including this guy here please say
something and I mean I I have to includ
this in the wrong category that's no one
hating on the game the game amazing
whole
journey you post on
Twitter was amazing you know see the
reception was on were along with the
strong 2023 for game for cyber
2077 for all of you thank you so much
thank you thank
you that's crazy how arcane made it very
clear yo it's third person calm down
love congratulations guys our next guest
has worked on some truly memorable
everyone's tagging me right now
everyone's tagging I got to see the gaml
but it's feeling
so it feels it does feel Shady but I
need to see I need to
[Music]
see listening to the rul I've been with
you that whole time too about that just
one and and I do want to see a more
photo realistic type you know a more
realistic
game I don't care a
Marvel
diverse grounded coolest characters in
The Cinematic that makes sense in a
video game fully original you would say
one futuristic open world game no
tonight it's a
new it has everything except that it's
it's a sequ sneak peek what we've been
working on it's a lot of walking and
seriously I'm so excited so much I won't
take it away from that it's literally
only because it's
first the second one might be way better
so everyone is tagging me hash just one
on Twitter this is crazy
over I'm sorry let me pay attention to
the show oh what's
this light
speed you for real holding back that
robot oh mommy oh don't do that in front
of the
kids front of
I'm scared sure for sure please push now
oh it's
going going to be okay the demon is here
the demon is here it's the demon demon
coima
Studio it's the
demon oh
Kira the demon is here
m
choreography is crazy
woo are you the
demon like the character design follow
me demon this looks really good though
[Music]
yes oh all right girl all right all
right with the motorcycle right baby
girl what we doing with little ghost
wide too background what's going on over
here Philip said gun you know what I
love I love that King and S both
watching this but they couldn't be but
they here yeah they slick last
senal last senal game okay for who for
what the plat is
more the same game is this more of it
that's tring
to this is a new
game lift your head death stranding too
death stranding
too
I know that
background now open your eyes I got a
package for you I got a package baby
that's the embodiment of Xbox tax right
there put all your hopes in me take a
breath and look around
you he D oh no it
ain't what the hell what what is this
this is your world right here I
mean it look like it's in death
stranding though like the biome looks
death stranding does it really does like
they literally if it's not death
stranding like they got the death
stranding biome FY
star yeah maybe fate always tests I like
that like that you have to fight I like
the uh the the best video game War they
had years yeah this is by far
so that's of world M tons of wel man
some of the best wel the first
descendant yeah I have heard of this Jo
I've heard of this
yes okay
okay that was the first descendant which
is launching the summer of 2024 from
next on now we have a new look at hoyo
versus Next Big Game zenis Zone zero in
urban fantasy arpg I have my eye on this
one for Gamescom and we're excited to
unveil their latest announcement right
here at TGA
so many yo they have so many world
premieres this is crazy
M all right what we doing love this this
what we doing what's going on yeah I was
waiting for this one right here yeah
this is it
joint no Persona energy all right look
when there's C ear I'm I'm I'm here bro
you here for the C I'm here for the C
I'm here for
it it's not looking good for you what
happened
now you and soft picked a lot of the
same games going forward I know I know I
know it's a WRA we we stayed that's why
part of me wanted to
do you could still win but it's probably
no chance for me if I don't have enough
different
choices now what does the winner take
it's bragging right I think KN and knees
all right knees no uh you pick different
multiplayer yeah it ain't looking
good holding out so there still there
there is two awards that you have that
you have different picks on still cuz we
all pick the same game of the year got
it calling now this is game of the year
next
year
d b b
[Applause]
so about to win this
again gam stuff what is is
this okay
okay
Assa like
Optimus Optimus what's going
on looks like Gundam yeah little Gundam
little little zone of the Enders a
little what were we
doing look crazy I'm not a fan but it
looks nice yeah it looks nice got the
aerial Bots all
right it might as well be Mecha Sal
yeah
that
an okay ricus
TI what isn't zampella supposed to be
here it's the eler ring
expion new Elder ring I
quit that's supposed to be here too
Elder ring
expion man there's too many games is so
many bro
that we brought in Gamers to demo the
latest cyberpunk update I have not told
cyberpunk
update no I can't wait CU
uhal skate man put about do you things
powering your gaming close to 100 hours
you're actually playing on a
chome streaming on GeForce now beat the
whole
game I I love balers gate so much that
when I got to act three I started
another playthrough cuz I don't want to
beat it yet
so uh if it goes into Game Pass like I
think it will I'll start a third play
the tide of war is turning against
us as we battle against our
bugs you know this game looks pretty
good to
me I need to see
more and spread there's some things that
kind of look Jank but yeah that's like a
little the movement yeah that I think
that's where it's that's the in game
portion yo you stupid see this in a lot
of fun it's proba a fun
game it reminds me kind of like a
outrider yes yeah like a a little like
lower quality but more things going on
in the background dude I would love an
out rers 2 I really like that I would
for Freedom en list today I'd like it
more in Game Pass though
mhm PlayStation does have
limits Aaron Greenberg like the Tweet
some say it's coming to Xbox at the very
least something I guess the discussion
online addict is if blade is
multiplatform or
not
M Aaron Greenberg like the Tweet what is
your pledge about the uh what you call
it
um just same to say coming to Xbox at
least all
guys it's
exclusive
exclusive okay now we have a special
surprise for you live and exclusively
here at the game
award welcome welcome
welcome I am your host Wen door is this
and I present to you the old gods of
Asgard featuring that bestselling writer
Alan Wick
this is Harold of Darkness of Darkness
what is this oh this the album yeah I'm
been trying this down cuz I think this
will yeah yeah we going get hit with the
copyright get flag yep yeah we go get
flagged real quick so what y'all think
because uh the talk on Twitter now is is
it is blade exclusive or not why would
it not be it has to be hit say makes you
wonder why they would leave platforms
off this is the only trailer that did
that it does men Marvel as a
co-publisher makes you
wonder yeah but also Indiana Jones is
exclusive and it's Disney too
so yeah I highly doubt that it's multi
Arcane I just it has to
be but if it is so what I don't care
long as we get on Game Pass Game Pass
Game Pass for the win y go ahead and buy
it hurt your pockets we'll get on Game
Pass
no that if that's not exclusive that's
an
i i a game
passus crazy right now I don't I I don't
care if it's coming to Game Pass or not
like Xbox needs its
own uh comic book hero game and if they
just if they if they having their own
people make stuff uh to go on the other
platform knowing they already have
Spiderman just twe tweeted we're excited
to announc Marvel's blade is in
development with Arcane Leon the AR
award winning Studio behind the S and
Def Loop in collaboration with Marvel
games Marvel Blade is a mature single
player third person game set in the
heart of Paris they St said all the
platforms but I mean development on
Marvel's blade has just begun but we're
thrilled to be able to make this
announcement in honor of blad's 50th
anniversary I love the fact that it's
third person and uh it's you know
it's it's a mature title uh that's
that's positive a lot of people are
saying a lot of people are asking if
it's coming to PlayStation 5 but no
one's said anything yet I feel like
PlayStation keep like someone would be
tweeting uh Marvel yeah let's look at
the Sony account yes someone would be
probably not PlayStation but at least
Sony would be uh play Marvel right cuz
if it was coming let's
see okay PlayStation tweeted an hour ago
rise of the Ronin
and the Kratos DLC that was the last two
tweets from
PlayStation I would tend to agree with
you adct because if it was coming they
would
have they would have flexed that they
would have flexed that somebody would
have leaked something yeah so I feel
so because they always do that stuff
with Sony right every time Xbox
announces something and it's multiplat
they somebody from the Sony side always
shows something on Twitter it's also
coming to you know our platform always
doesn't matter at the end of the day
yeah a Marvel Blade Games coming bro
yeah I'm super excited Game Pass day one
no it matters if it's exclusive or no oh
no no it's mad
Dam that's console war stuff man no it's
not console war stuff it's value to the
ecosystem what are you talking about
we've been streaming for value is Game
Pass I don't care about Game Pass you
want pay bucks or you want
I don't care about the value with 200
other
games the only tweets have been all
night yeah we were debating if this
PlayStation Aaron Greenberg commented
play played on Xbox 100% let me see all
right somebody in the chat said greeny
commented on it let's
see
greeny let's see cuz greeny would be the
first to
say he said an Xbox but I didn't see him
say say anything exclusive but he did
say everyone involved to bring that
performance to only see right here on
the game awards now it's time for an
update on a game we announced back at
TGA in
GTFO is it fin coming to consoles yeah
Shar the same story the same fate
a family of
strangers a stranger fact drunken ninja
Xbox gets blade if it wasn't for blade
be no MC fact here's my thing we have
died a thousand times if Indiana Jones
was a multiplay I would be more inclined
but you need tell me that they fought
for Indiana johns but going fight for
Blaze I I agree with you it's just that
people you know how people are right and
there's going to be a certain base
that's going to keep asking until they
definitively say it
my friend okay so I just looked it up
online it says Marvel's blade is being
developed exclusively for Xbox and
Windows PC where you saw oh where you
see that Google it REM that's where
that's the first thing I see from
where's the source coming from I'm going
to the goog Windows Central I believe oh
okay then yeah I I I I mean I was told
it was exclusive too joining me now is
Ol from 10 Chambers crazy that was six
years ago we announced gtf and that's
the Final Chapter you've got a free
weekend on Steam look fantastic
everybody is bullying me on Twitter to
answer the
question yeah first of all I have to say
thank we got to find out if it's
exclus I just need to see more game
that's
all the suit is [__]
amazing you look good too your game look
great anyway uh yeah we're working on
something new and uh it's like a passion
project like like all our projects are
and this you know for payday things like
that so back back some Heist stuff I
guess yeah yeah yeah so now we're back
to doing a heist game again and it's
sort of a a SciFi thing that Mar will be
exclusive to Xbox series X S Windows PC
and we
launch yes we should working on
this Google Che out the new G Chambers
here we go it pops up away CL release
from from what you call it I threw the
link in the on our chat P cancel the
reservation reset the procedure couple
paragraphs Down May severely damage the
reset the
procedure Morris coming for you f he
said you wrong on exclusively blade sell
subscriptions and Xbox Xbox it matters
was just spilling the beans about your
recent oh they can come for me all they
want my opinion I I'm not saying I'm not
saying what will happen to this or that
all I care about is my wallet as long as
a game is in Game Pass I am happy I feel
that I feel that I'm happy my wallet's
happy we no you Fu no you
didn't what were you looking
forers get their
bag Desy what's
this
yes wild
crazy I'm going PC eventually not what
Mr Bowman Mr Bowman oh wait a minute
this is Mr Bowman I name sound familiar
me you CAU here you're caught in the den
of wol the hell is this den of wol some
payday
type no Str you're right Shane I see you
man make a boys is the boys yeah Bo
would make an excellent the boys the TV
show oh okay okay that' make an
excellent game
rebirth y they the amount of trailers
and new games at this a show it's better
than we've seen in years ever oh yeah
yeah I'll go
I'll
Jesus the non-stop games and majority of
them look
phenomenal
yeah remember when there was just a
handful of developers that can really do
that photo realism now you see so many
more doing that so true it's so
[Music]
crazy yeah adct I dropped a link in the
zoom chat that says blade suppos be
exclusive and day
one Rockstar still to go to open world
games
this game looks kind of cool right yeah
it looks sick twitch chat is crazy
they're saying fortnite 4 Destiny
3 easy easy
out what
happened to adct what you laughing
at ex
exor this game look good too wish lless
coming on forms level infinite makes it
okay I think that's tense that was exob
I met with the team at Gamescom to take
a look at that upcoming tactical open
world extraction shooter and the project
is led by some of the creators of the
division and besides facing other
players and Waring factions vertical
gameplay as you saw the forces of nature
unlock the potential of the players EXO
rigs to help away about that EXO name is
coming in24 on exob now please welcome
the voice of Loki in asgard's Wrath 2
one of theous and anticipated offing all
take the gym and eat healthy so we can
live long enough to play these games
factual health is wealth yo you got to
be a oh asard raft crazy VR Game Crazy
supped to get a copy of that when my
meta so beyond excited to show you this
trailer for our this is probably one of
the most exciting games working with the
sanzaru team and bringing Wy to life
it's just been Absolut
amazing after playing asgard's rra 2 as
a
boy honestly blown away so uh I'm
honored to be a part of this franchise
and want to thank everyone at senaro
games at Oculus Studios and meta Quest
yeah so without further Ado let's enjoy
the trailer for adsg guard is crazy the
scope of this game in VR is absolutely
nut wild when I was watching trailer
tell know there's one game to give a
shot y y'all been screaming for full
games just the one to give a shot to
it looks all right hands
dry and I seen that demo
battles turn
World heada instantly he that a
headache you allowed Loki to De tion
sickness would hit me hard now his chaos
got try it on Quest three brother the
quest three is is sick man un Demand
Being that I had the two and now the
three with each
possession the AR on the three
will pass through M yeah when I first
open it up and they have that little
intro flying around the
room MH oh we cut heads off beautiful
Guardian here to write your
wrong
other V until until I fall fishing jazz
is
in jazz is in we got
[Applause]
you oh
creepy that's sick god
Ra there is no time or place you can
hide that's crazy I'm curious about that
Mo your fate is mine that's
too oh wait December
15th meta three yep pack I did I'm ready
for it
ready TJ
foolish oblivious to the chaos that
awaits you just
outside oh see you sooner than you
think why is she standing there like
that what the amazing year not just for
games but for adaptations of the games
we love right now we have an exclusive
look at the highly anticipated new
series Fallout uh oh somebody get Maddy
somebody get Anchor Man oh hello there
now how about we turn on some lights
water
gaggin
[Music]
are we going to see a death CL though
you know we will eventually they go they
got to build that
[Music]
up well you know what they
say war never
changes
what good man Amazon PL looks
[Applause]
[Music]
good from Fallout please welcome
Mell and let them announce no Fallout
game man you going he going to
lose the cash what's up y'all uh don't
mind we brought a little EXT
secur thank you for having us and we are
incredibly excited for you all to see
pull out on Prime this April but our
real honor tonight is that we're here to
hand out the award for best ad
adaptation I think I know what I picked
for this one I'm the only one that
picked something different I picked
Mario you all picked Last of Us of
bosses are here what oh god
Howard the God is here the God is
here right for respect good catch
buddy yeah but we should probably hurry
this up I don't think he can breathe in
there yeah how how you doing big
man okay all right all right let's go
okay so this year video games and film
and television bigger and better than
ever before here are the nominees for
best adaptation I think it's going to be
last best
adaptation the vampire Messiah will come
pray for you
Victor I ever
[Music]
want there we go yeah there we go going
on that so good remember was fire though
I'm not going hold
you world F that's where the cars and
guns come in last of us was good wow wow
uh the best game goes to I me Twisted
Metal The Last of Us
yeah Pedro's in the Builder oh no drop
man this got so much look Anthony Macky
though hey was was this about the TV
show or something yeah the
HBO Dr see you at the New York Gable one
soon
[Applause]
[Music]
brother somebody said RI not deserve
damn y'all
hating all right uh okay clock's
sticking uh shout out to my
partner watching up in Canada getting
ready for season two uh huge thank out
to our n dog family this wouldn't exist
without all your incredible hard work uh
big thanks to HBO and the support
they've given us and a lot uh big thans
to Our Last of Us Community none of this
exists Without You window man we also
want to thank our partners the Sony
Pictures special shout out to Carter
Swan and the whole PlayStation
Productions Team PlayStation thanks so
much thank you oh you forget it well you
forget where the checks is
[Applause]
done
big man but they still
check like that suit though Fallout that
suit is fire captur on Nintendo switch
uhoh I just traed in my switch I just
traed in my switch I didn't play oh you
did I I just didn't play it oh
I this isn't to me this is not an award
show it's a marketing show it's always
been I mean we welcome to the party but
we can still fight wor it's been though
this is by far the worst has been I
think it's I mean I think it's a
fantastic show it's just that we know
what the priorities are
until yeah you don't like this game
[Music]
mtic I've been waiting for this
one probably number two on my most
anticipated all time yeah it is right
behind that racing game from earlier
right yeah uh whatever that was whatever
the tail whip game ta
[Music]
whip golden hair what I like that there
you go Pia goou or whatever his name
is what is
this this is a mature Pokemon what is
this oh this is that new PlayStation
game
tell what the hell is
this what is going
[Applause]
on koku man get it right it's
now what is he Monster Hunter now mobile
man why' it give me so hyp
for when I was younger struggling with
who I was what my place was I took a lot
of that anxiety and put it into making
games and it's evolved over time
especially as I've gotten into AAA guess
what
everybody hindsight is a narrative
exploration
yeah Google somebody put it what you
need to know Arcane
Leon the developer behind the news broke
as arane Leon is an Xbox Studio Marvel's
blade is being developed exclusively for
Xbox series x/s and Windows PC and also
launch day one I doing
I that's the one I put in the chat
y just makes Meer we will not Retreat
this B is
guy pass oh my God look at the updates
this is insane they got Vehicles now
this is
crazy I really didn't see this game last
as long as it has you know the trouble
was in the beginning oh yeah the turn
around the commitment
[Music]
M whole promise over like the promise
multiplayer but not really multiplayer
one thing I'll say is I've officially
laid off no man SC they they they
redeemed so boy this is
overkill with um just a comeback story
Redemption but now better than what the
original vision seems like oh that look
[Music]
crazy fractal I remember
like
thieves that game was the first the
M it is awesome now the journey star
like Star Citizen need sport
yeah Journey
continues yeah when did that I thought
that game like close to launch with
PlayStation right that thing that was
a that right there was no man's Sky a
game we announced 10 years ago with this
guy right here Shawn Murray Sean uh
looks like the content keeps rolling in
2024 but what does the next decade look
like for Hello Games well to start with
uh next year is going to be a really big
year for no man sky like you said I've
been working on it for 10 years now and
I still really love it still really
enjoy it but what people don't know is
that for the last years we've been
work another game what we doing
something very different something maybe
more no man SC two no man SC uh here we
go oh tell us a bit about it Sean uh
well for no man Sky we generated a whole
universe of kind of sparse alien looking
planets and that wasn't easy you know
hard but there is something that's much
harder that we wanted to do uh for our
new game we wanted to create an earth um
you know something as varied a planet
that is as varied as a universe
something bigger than Earth something
with you know mountains real mountains
not video game mountains but mountains
that are Miles High taller than Everest
that when you climb to the top of them
and look out you can see rivers and
canyons and continents you know you can
see oceans so is this like an open world
Planet kind of thing yeah I mean the
first real open world right
something got Y in trouble the first
time show the thing bro I'm telling you
they going to quote you and then this
how we started in trouble with interview
I love you together well
we look at it just we have anything
tonight or future or yes please show so
we have a trailer um and you know it's
quite a small team that's working on us
there's about a dozen of us actually
everyone's here the the everyone from
the team is here uh
we're uh we're very excited to share
this
wrap it up let's go super nervous you
know but uh really excited if you know
if people like it this is a game I would
like to still be updating 10 years from
now all right so game awards
so let's take a look this is such an
incredible project let go let's go come
let's go should we do it Sean let's do
it now here we go
oh okay we getting a peek at it
multiplayer Earth
procedural Earth yeah F stupid fantasy
unexplored
Earth all footage in-game
[Music]
multiplayer looks a lot like no man's
guy influences
but you know what I'm glad that they
were able to make this game because when
they first launched snowman's Sky oh boy
and you would have told me right now
they're making another game I would have
said you're lying you're
lying getting on back of
dragon dragon they're trying to go
for everything you
stupid they're trying to go for uh what
got Dam bird the game that dizzy and
John used play all the time art yeah
they going for
art
fornite fornite oh we got the islands
okay oh yeah cat
man so be called No Man's Earth no man's
Earth no man's
Earth the bend the me rabbits oh my God
we got we got cat people we got rabbit
people
mhm
okay uhoh all right all right we got
enemies we got bosses what we doing
what's going on down
below somebody said we got oh y'
messing oh the same kind of symbol light
no fire interesting
interesting all
right remember that comes from an
independent team absolutely incredible
I've waiting years show that to you and
again created by the team at hello games
so uh very very exciting and I'm excited
to uh see games like that that show kind
of the next decade of where games are
going hopefully TGA too right now join
me in welcoming to the stage actor simu
Liu
uhoh all right get Blade oh what
happened to your leg bro oh give him a
second oh I'm not going to get my myeni
what
happened everybody how y'all doing
tonight my God there's so many of you
you guys all look so so beautiful um all
right first off I want to address the
elephant in the room um my foot's fine
you guys I I did tear my achilles uh I
wasn't riding a dragon I was playing
pickup basketball in
Miami I wish I wish there were a better
story to this you guys but the story is
this um you know as you age as you get
older you know particularly as you cross
the 30 threshold your body starts to
break down all right things start
happening don't
apply um guys just if you're not Anthony
Mackey learn to appreciate the
importance of stretching all right it's
very important um just keeping it real
at the game awards all right now I'm
here to sh one of only good movies that
Marvel G in the I recently got a chance
to team up with frost Giant on their new
realtime strategy game storm game now
RTS is a genre that I was absolutely
obsessed with as a kid I loved building
armies and obliterating my enemies of
Empire man and conqueror of course my
absolute alltime favorite game Starcraft
mhm yes so happy you guys cheered for
that um now if you've been destroyed
bybox get get that contract for Shen
next after blade and that's why I so
excited for stormgate look it's a noob
Strat I understand all right but I loved
it look that's why I love stormgate it
was made by a team of EX Starcraft
developers who are just as obsessed with
RTS as I am and in addition to
competitive and Co-op modes in the game
it's got an ongoing campaign that was
written by Frost giant With a Little
Help from the legendary Chris medson and
so yes I brought a little bit of
gameplay for y'all and the first reveal
of a pretty badass new
I may or may not have gotten the voice
let's let's have a
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
look
storm shut it
off shut it off sure
stupid it is too late my
friend
we got a situation on our
hand in God's name have we
done
release the is
s there you go there's your game
play list my friends they friends Great
Value Starcraft oh that's
bloody there you
go very Hal wary
I may or may not have played this
oh attic exclusive storm gate fight C
either way your world will fall oh there
you
go not for me cheap yall can keep this y
mess yeah it's not I knew that was
you see I'm happy for the people who are
happy about that pretty good right
and uh and now it's time to hand out the
next award here are the nominees for
best action adventure
all best action adventure
game out
of either way this is something else
miles get in over him we can fight this
together you're so Spiderman
what no this might be their
chance I kind of want a Jedi WI of an
Empire I
love he said Zelda outside y you stupid
said you know who
in the game award goes
to No Surprise here Legend the tears of
the Kingdom we
all I don't even mess with
this there we
go it's St first time up here he getting
a little mad he been sitting for a
while is Spiderman going to sit on goose
eggs the whole show
[Applause]
[Music]
well you got the
speech I'm so glad to be able to be here
to award on behalf of everyone who
worked together to create this
game hey what about
everyone on the development team truly
uh uh gave their all in in making this
game the best it would be funny if he's
not saying anything but I told y'all to
put respect on my name how many times we
going to keep coming up here droing
Zelda games and winning this whole
show what if he really pop it off in his
D he didn't really say
every
own talking that what if he stayed in on
business right now thank you so
much don't you ever drop your game on on
my release
date don't come at
[Applause]
us congratulations Mr anuma and I am
happy now to announce winners in a few
more categories at the game awards here
are the nominees for best
RPG balers Gate 3 final
fantasy
of only nomination award goes
to we all piic
that here are the nominees for best
Sim Wars and re Camp City skylines 2
company of
hero emblem engage and Pikman four and
the game Bo goes to Pikman four who pick
we all pick what we pick here are the
Nomes
get3 for Motorsport Hot Wheels unleash
two turbo and the crew motorest and this
year the game award goes to yeah turn
10 m
Diablo
Street Super Mario Brother and the game
award goes to none of us won damn it
having a pretty good night nominees for
our players voice award
100% balers Gate 3 cyber punk7 Phantom
Liberty impact Marvel Spiderman 2 and
The Legend of Zelda tear of the Kingdom
and The Game award goes to Bal Jes they
flooding the street congratulations Lar
Gap is let's take a look now at this
spectacular celebration gaming on sphere
from Google that was the only shot
because that was when we picked
something different in the other
category and we we didn't win the other
game
one so last the last one's forth two
points y all the
same which game we all pick different I
think it was RPG I think there people
mad about why why is chat mad got it
what's going but I think we picked the
same
no we
did you die with s okay if he if it if
get best game direction is Allen wake to
okay cuz you said B's gate and he said I
to so he can blow me out or I can
tie if I tie that's a win that's a win
oh that's a win that's a win I'll beat
him I don't care what nobody say
my name is on top my name on top I don't
know about I don't care about what
anybody else
do isn't it technically if there's like
a boxing match and there's a draw
between it the champion I mean I mean b
theault is the guy that's supposed to
win you know the hearts of the people
you oh check this out man this is
awesome Guilty Gear look this guilty
what are they going to end this [__]
with
I thought you were going to say when are
they going to end guilty gears
but BR there's a lot of these types of
games that's where's my boo celebrating
somewhere what's up with all these types
of games these anime
yeah anime gotp
on
tell next year Sol first
[Applause]
I'm winning y got to do something y got
to do something crazy with like the next
year with the last question like maybe
like five points or something and then
like lock out your answer you can't have
the same answer you got to lock them
[Applause]
out mad long they going
in I'm making a video tomorrow I'm not
fighting game
fgc new game mode four on four three on
three Team
Battle here you go f all
you you're
stupid stress City baby people be having
you stress down here tell me if that
didn't drop tonight Shadow drop you
wouldn't play it uh-oh what's this this
is
[Music]
art that is this R2 energy we'll see but
it's art it's art they got the
music that's crazy they Riding Dragons
that's crazy they always dragons that's
crazy yeah yeah you got giant monkeys
spiders Play now play what now oh
okay waiting for the
name all
right all right welcome back to the game
awards we still got some awards to hand
out Timothy sham will be here to help
and we have some more World premieres
including Jesus they are not
stabbing Square
Enix creative business unit it's yeah
it's creative business
unit look good though whatever that is
yeah I don't like new DLC Crystal
are we hyped about this enlightened
Souls I'm not hyp
either more action did 16 win any any
rewards yes it won it didn't win a game
it won um score somebody's woken this
place it had a good score it deserves
that question is and Ben star acting he
deserved a shot too I surprised he
didn't win that
[Music]
one I what the hell is an IC I do not
enjoy the combat in this game to find
out beautiful looking game like the
answer it is it is got a good narrative
and stuff yeah I got you all the B
battles for QT I feel that welcome my
friends toia Rising
TI best sound oh my yo who Steve be
relax
yourself you're ridiculous when's
PlayStation going to get a new IP you
know always ask of Xbox oh man I like
the DLC for fin6 DLC for Ragnarok yo
y'all
m y are you implying
that before the final battle in Final
Fantasy
PlayStation was exclusive now to present
our next Award Best Game Direction
please welcome one of our industry's
greatest creative forces the creator of
Call of Duty glob GM for Star Wars Jedi
Battlefield Titan Vella Legends the goat
let's go respawn in the building got to
get you on the IL St we got good what's
going
on if it's bers gate
three Cog will be tied with sa I need to
be for first so game design can be chaos
actually let me rephrase that the best
game design is almost always part chaos
right uh today it's really normal for
teams of hundreds to work for years on
huge open worlds that are condensed into
one pack when that chaos has somehow
been harnessed into a cohesive artistic
expression that's great game design so
tonight I'm proud to present the
nominees for best game soft
pick best game
Direction you
pick
I could be in trouble here yeah I could
be in trouble together we must
survive that's B gate
about best direction for Spider-Man you
[__] kidding me beautiful
day link you are our final hope you must
find
me amazing
great here you
go W two all right I'm going to bed I'm
going cry in the car get it
again did it
[Applause]
again me and now you're in third
oh
no I've never been so mad at
all shout out to Sam leg the
team
second lost right at the end we want to
thank epic s go to bed I don't want to
see you in chat I don't want see you
tweeting I want hear nothing
for vision Gat going to win gam
direction is nothing without a
team tears of the Kingdom I would have
pick tears of you know what here's the
thing tears of the kingdom is pretty
huge too joining us of course on this
yeah
I'm between those two games a fool he
said all those muscles
what do my p man the question is the
question is how close
is
C trap something out of it disrespectful
we
all make art and we can be more than
some of our right at the end C wanted to
pick of the Kingdom for I would got smok
heart so interesting if it's tears of
the Kingdom then that would but I still
even
if right now I'm down I'm down
by thanks oh thank
you it's a win quotation
Mar yeah my mind in my
[Laughter]
[Music]
mind what going going crazy please
welcome Gustav the creative director of
the finals oh the finals remember we saw
that
joint that a multiplayer joint that look
kind of cool I think it's the
battlefield
[Music]
people when we started building this
game we set a bold vision for ourselves
we said that if we're going to make a
shooter it needs to be unique it needs
to be something that no one else is
doing standing here today I'm so proud
and grateful for the amazing team at
Embark Studios where who help make this
crazy dream a reality and of course to
all of you our amazing players watching
you play the finals has been the most
gratifying experience of my entire
career you're not just a part of this
journey you guide us and you inspire us
and I love you for that now let's watch
our latest trailer and keep your eyes
peeled for the launch date at the very
end it might be sooner it is tonight
thank you and enjoy but we haven't got
the bers day drop yet
[Applause]
oh yeah that's true yeah larion hasn't
come out
right and Xbox is already like
shared oh heck that look great what is
[Music]
thisin Roof oh BG start in trouble on
Twitter what' he say he said blade over
Wolverine argue with your mama oh damn
oh
wow they taxing
hard j y that's messy that is wild
messy no room for the here at the
final
[Applause]
oh yo they clowning me on Twitter oh no
th did it again car going cry in the car
he never going to
be they are destroying the only person
that's never want to crowd your life why
you had to bring that up on the stream
though like like we didn't need to know
these details like
that supposed to be my man you had to do
me like that You' be so
cruel own Brothers it be your own
Brothers sometimes
[Laughter]
man that's right the finals is out
tonight on
steamx and Playstation out the show The
Game Awards in fortnite well all month
fans
user created island of the and the
winner is Fort congratulations you can
portal to the winning Island from our
TGA map while you're there collect all
the
TGA unlock those Peter
Griffin with the crown is below still to
come the presentation of Game of the
Year featuring our our orchestral salute
to the
nominees almost there the end boys
what time is this over I mean I guess it
theoretically should be like 11: but
this like it might go 115 1130 EST
that's why
I I had some H for gear six that cool
little update on that little update but
I'll take a blade game blade is fire I
take oan
Studios gate three okay okay game of the
generation right here
people the others belongs to fortnite we
go
Destiny the new Pinnacle excels in every
area now according to King Phil is going
to come out on stage he said right now
they except the reward except the award
fan the Mind
flare just wait B Jesus oh they flexing
early said y'all know what it is coming
up
I see the tens on the screen we flooded
your screen yall know what that was
subliminal that was a shot and body body
the Game of the Year y'all Deluxe yo
they Flex it heavy in the street
somebody said overrated is going to be
forgotten by New Year's bro that game is
been popular for two two and a half
years could lead to a huge
[Music]
Revolution
betrayal
come on youry
Destiny step
boys
betrayal all night you've been voting on
Twitch get shorter and shorter every
time after the
che R The Winner Street here all right
this is it awesome thanks Sydney well
now it's time for tonight's final
world that's right we're getting towards
the end of the show and this one I will
let speak all right so they say this is
the biggest game they saved towards the
end all right let's see what this is
them crocodiles
though crocodiles I like that morphing
into the ground
crocodile act like I a see that I'm
going act like that that's the hter what
is it oh mo Monster
Hunter yep yep Mo Monster
Hunter for those all the animals they
all be saving each week whenever yall
get the likes up those all the different
animals you know what they say I'm happy
for those that are happy that's the new
joint now yeah when you not feeling it
yeah I'm happy for those who are happy
about this yes yes I'm happy for those
salute salute to those guys salute to
you guys I'm happy that you're
happy now this is a huge franchise huge
I'm shocked that they got the final spot
bro that must like but how huge is
Monster Hunter right for them to get the
like the the big
Premiere again it was it really didn't
show much either worlds
Wilds
jail to be honest yeah I'm surprised
this they capcon had that bread 2025 all
right they had the last spot they had
the last SP over everything wow somebody
said
whack yo y'all fou please welcome to the
stage Monster Hunter series producer
rioo tuoto it's
so at the game awards y going to
recognize what we do out
here
you're going to play
it I see yall talking in the side I see
all you over there you over there I see
you but we got the biggest game out here
in the streets and I'm holding twice to
let you
know that's right see Ang I'm very happy
aggressive it was aggressive was
aggressive
wasg aggressive Steve in
September right see release in
2025 wow uh I think everyone wants to
know when do they get to see more on
this any sense of when we're going to
see more on this gu you see it when I
tell damn well you see it and I see you
fix your face right there in row six in
in the back fix your face over
there fix your face you see it when I
tell you you going to see it cuz we them
do bus said I'm coming for your neck
of
my you know when he gri the mic with two
hands he letting you know what time it
is this
game in bars right now we plan on
revealing more information about this
game
CLE he said she clean it up when
celebrating his 40th anniversary I would
like to thank all of the Capcom fans
that's right that app track all years we
couldn't have done it without you inity
in the eye look like say it more
aggressively though fun games uh and The
Best Is Yet To Come that's right we got
the top spot that's right top spot now
to present Game of the Year from the
up budget is please welcome YouTuber
modded controller 3 bag for this one
somebody said where the [__] I saw that
I'm messy
weing ain't till 2025 just having fun
y'all Sony didn't have enough
money imagination passion and Technical
Brilliance of the six nominees for the
game of the year were truly inspiring
here with a medle celebrating each of
these games once again Lauren Bal and
the game awards
Orchestra they cheated me out of my
Starfield music right here I know yeah I
I I think Starfield music is beautiful
oh I would have me I on right now I on
call what if it's Zelda yo I it could be
it could and I should have went with my
heart hey you should with your heart I
go I went with my
[Music]
head like I said it should be between
Zelda and uh balers gate truly
should b g is the people
CH damn look at this get down oh he's
he's a beast with the flute oh man flute
gu
back FL gu look
like he was seated he still looked like
he was
killing look at the drummer too look oh
yo look at the head Bop look at the head
BB
son oh I like the flute guy and the
drummer hey they need to be a Duo for
get the orchestra just them
energy trumpet
said Wonder check him out on the end bro
he need a stand he's like I don't he's
on one bro this is why Co loses he
didn't put himself in the shoes of the
folders like s all right
man relax you
yo that guy forgot his toat he's just
wearing his white
t screw it
y oh there oh look at the foot he about
to go
in about to go in
Son bro I think he should win game of
the
year look at that foot t
[Music]
look he's about to get all the
women everybody else is looking down at
their notes he's just Ving yeah bro he
don't need the notes he don't need the
notes
freak I just dropped a
mol there he goes there he go just
dropped the mol
already he going
in oh we standing up now yeah oh oh oh
what he got the big guns what he pull
out what he pull out he got
a oh I'm playing with y'all right now
yall going to recognize his talent going
to [__] keep the camera on me that's it
keep it on me I'm the best out here
doing it Y
what give him his pen give him his pen
man said y'all going to know his name
made up a new instrument for the show
bro he said y thought this was a
game we got another Jo got a little he's
just switching flutes like nobody do
this
bro oh man all the
artillery I like that guy I like that
guy you know what now when they have
theatrics like that and they got a dude
on stage like that that's when I'm okay
with it I want to see that energy I want
to see guys no joke out
here that guy is
awesome here we
go
and the game of the year
is balers gate three let's go let's go
salute lar salute to they came ready he
came with his arm that boy ready that
boy ready oh man go said first of his
name Lord larion first of his name I
have come to claim and Conquer your game
awards Royal Flush in multiple character
categories going get a Spider-Man doll
put it out there he's going to
go turn base let's
go y y are
Champion um I didn't expect it anymore
um thank you thank you so much I think
that's a real Ste he not playing with
yall we do this for real and watch Phil
Phil come on a real horse right now
spent their hearts and souls listen what
he said on this game in sometimes very
difficult circumstances this was our Co
game um in Co along the way we we lost
quite a few people also so we want to
dedicate this uh to all the people we
lost and especially uh to Jim our lead
cinematic uh artist uh who passed away
that's right give it up Put Put Your
Hands Together Dam it that's right um
real I want Tok out here over 2,000
people so sit back and
relax uh but uh I also uh want to thank
everybody that's supported us throughout
this entire uh effort uh our families
our friends our partners uh you were the
best and without you we couldn't have
done it thank you very much got snub the
chip the chip is here Spiderman got
Goose got yeah Spider-Man
anything time
czy happy
happy congratulations SP congratulations
to all of tonight I thought they were
going to give the release date for the
Xbox we get
that
what get THS December
12th
[Music]
back they were supposed to say it's now
in Game Pass go play it go play it right
the coordinated they fo [__] wash his
hand over here wash his hand shout out
to uh nend out tackle Xbox tookes home
than
PlayStation what if they did it on
social media check the social medias
maybe they just did it as like a drop
I'm kind of upset they didn't say
anything though they said that we'll see
you at the show and we'll give you the
date yeah you're right did they say that
laran that interesting let's see anybody
check the social medias real quick I
can't stay on too long I need to know I
think he was a bit lightheaded with all
that armor he was wearing on the whole
show I mean he wore that the whole shirt
that is dedication bro he was ready you
uncomfortable he must have been you
imagine if they wouldn't have won either
what if he had to go to the bathroom
that was three hours that's right that
was three hours that was three hours
factual anybody got let me see laran
let's see that bro fasting man he was
not freaking drinking or eating anything
a man believing in so he said we got
this we got this two minutes ago thank
you Game was truly incredible night 17
minutes there a patch up day 24 minutes
best multiplayer voice an hour no no I
don't see
any yeah no no yeah and I like see this
article saying it's about to be revealed
on the game show and it wasn't yeah
you're
right interesting they messed up not a
reliable wait Lucius Augustus BGA BS
Gate 3 out now on Xbox is that true no
is that
true that's my man Lu spent no no no
foolishness no foolish
he usually be on point on the line right
now it says 12 Lucius says yes he
popping off he said it's out now on Xbox
creeper also so they did they just
stealth dropped it okay okay so it did
so they said no he's trolling somebody
double check man turn on your Xbox find
out see it the live now somebody see
open up your game pass AB me go open up
your Xbox app go ahead open up your app
open up that Nintendo said it's true it
oh so it's a w y'all it's a w okay okay
let's check let's check though let's
check somebody get the confirmations out
open these apps up let's see it's not on
Game Pass though not on Game Pass but on
Xbox though CU if they didn't drop the
Xbox ver that' be even worse see Xbox
saying see you soon in studios three
hours ago that's all I you know what I
love the game so much I think I'm G to
buy it on the Xbox too yeah I want to
plus it's a cross some friends on there
why my Sony the genina over the 2 pound
Super Chat Sony one award for TV show
King will be insane Sunday
midnight JW is there that's what's right
now it's in the store all right seen how
much
699 pick that up right now download the
conso say download I still don't
understand that it's only 59 on Steam I
don't really so how much on Console
70 okay okay
okay uh we got to talk about that hideo
kajima game man cuz like
oh D what is it what is it that's the
question that's gonna hurt some brains
man it's gonna be twisted yeah man do F
overall on the show probably uh look if
we're talking about in terms of world
premieres and stuff I think it was an A+
I I think they showed a lot of cool
stuff um I just think that you know
again he likes to push a lot of
marketing and that's something I agree
with addict 100% like it's it's a little
too much I know you got to pay the bills
but can you pay some of those on your
own or something I don't know it's just
it's it's a lot it's a lot we're seeing
and if you're GNA play uh some ads and
stuff don't show the same ones over and
over like there was a couple that they
played a few a couple times and
fortnite yeah but no overall I I thought
it was the best show I've seen in a
while for for dip down what you where
you at man Game of Wars overall thoughts
your stand outs
where you at brother yeah know I'm
vibing what fwn said um terms of Game
Awards when it was actually on and live
amazing 10 out of 10 loved every second
of it the world premieres were just back
to back to back I mean it was it was
killer whenever the ads were rolling all
that stuff you know kind of a snooze
Fest but you know it seems like they try
to go extra every single year so that
bills getting a little bit higher each
and every year so creative how am I how
am I gonna pay for this year
um so it is what it is just comes with
the the territory um but in terms of a
show oh man it was it was amazing no
doubt did Starfield win one oh no
Starfield they were they're present they
pres they were present they were
there Spider-Man did not y messy y messy
see you're doing see you know it's it's
rightfully so they shouldn't have won
anything uh Spider-Man should enough
because yeah the categories it was in I
thought were just way outclassed by some
of the Nomine nominees in those same uh
categories yeah tough tough competitive
year addict where you at man game awards
how' you feel about it my mouth hurts a
lot right now oh I'm sorry um it was
good I I do think he he needs to go back
to the drawing table in order to balance
like the actual award thing you know in
previous years he's announced multiple
awards at once but usually it was one
time and he announced like three or four
and the rest there's a lot more going to
the stage I
like I
like
um I like Awards uh I like premieres
just as much as the next dude uh but at
the same time it's like the whole point
of this this event is the rewards and
when you're letting Muppets come out and
take more time than the actual people
that get to like it's like just you got
rid of the Muppets you probably going to
had two or three of those Rewards up on
there and it's just it doesn't sit right
with me CU it's just like it's
disrespectful you know it's mad
disrespectful and I see mad people in
the industry complaining about it right
now oh really yeah they're they're just
not happy with it cuz it's like look
like I understand that you know it's
it's it's hard to balance these two
things but I feel like there's a way to
do it and it needs to be handled better
cuz it's just like this was Borderland
District respectful to the people that
work their ass off for these games and
you me to tell me that if you're not
game of the year or like the only very
few people actually went to the stage
and got their
award very few maybe four that's true
like three hours yeah there wasn't a lot
obviously it was more than four but it's
just like you that was the most
disrespectful thing I think I've ever
seen them do and and I get it people are
like well adct you know we we care about
the war premieres and I care about the
war premieres I do but it's like could
have got you could have got rid of a
couple of them I'm going be real no it's
not even the world premieres they could
have got rid of the Gonzo they could
have got the Muppets and they could have
got rid of some of the orchestra stuff
like just think about coima was out
there for like 10 minutes y his segment
OD segment was long and it's like you
you mean to tell me coima was out there
for 10 minutes and you couldn't give two
or three more people that that space and
just let him like all those people that
announced games coima coima had a
backdrop he had doors the Heavenly door
bro and what did he give us a whole lot
of nothing right for 10 minutes a whole
lot of nothing disrespect like at the
end of the
day talking about attx now what happened
they need to do better I think that as
far as world premieres is the best year
he's ever had in World premieres by far
absolutely uh this was actually better
than a lot of like people's E3 showings
yes yeah no you're not wrong the last
one for me though the Monster Hunter
that was just little lack I was
surprised they got that spot yeah I was
surprised they got that spot even though
I know Monster Hunter is huge it is hug
you know next year this is a best show
they've done though even with all that
this is the best show they''re done but
it's just
like I don't like a a thing where
they're they're naming like [__] like
and he is literally naming
them off like they're nothing so oh in
the game uh best action adventure goes
to whatever he said oh and they're not
even showing the people or anything
which is you know something at least
I've always I've always complain about
that at least have them lined up to the
left and they just to the left it just
to the left it felt to me it just felt
disingenuous it was like you know I come
out here we we say this the Video Game
Awards but realistically it's not
and I think you know until you have that
balance I'm never going to give him 100%
it's like it's that that was a good
seven eight ad out out of 10 show it was
a fantastic show but it's called the
Video Game Awards and to me there was
not a lot of that going
on that's fair I'll jump in I think that
was an honest assessment look it was it
was probably the best game awards in the
last I don't know you know you could you
can make an argument it's probably one
of the best out of all of them that he's
ever done I thought um you know the
reveals the trailers were absolutely
stunning I mean this is literally what
the priority of the show is based on the
way their actions are right and it's
definitely marketing promotion trailers
and then Awards second and third but for
what they showed I thought was really
impressive I mean we got to give Xbox
showed out y'all we got to give complete
credit like they really had a flex I did
not expect to see multiple announcements
you know it's one thing to say oh you
might get an Arcane game then to find
out oh my God it's it's it's blade and
it's you know it's with them and it
looks like potentially exclusive then
you have you know the OD thing obviously
was a big de I didn't think it would be
ready to be to to be talked about a sh
even though it was just the you know the
static images of of whatever but and the
fact that Spider-Man W no rewards like
that's crazy you know what that shows me
about OD since you mentioned that is the
fact that it seems like Xbox really
wanted to show out yes they really did
they really yeah they did forget the
hellblade cont hell blade I was just
about to go there hell blade being there
yeah do you remember a few okay so it
was just a couple of years ago when when
they were talking about how they didn't
want to show anything too far out but
now they're showing stuff that's just
getting developed now starting
development well I think and I've been
saying they should do that for a long
time i' I've been saying hey Sony does
it and it works yeah you need to get the
fans hype and this kind of stuff gets
him hype blade even though I'm not a big
freaking Arcane fan MH Blade the I you
know this IP gets me hype I've been
wanting a blade game for so long we're
finally getting it and it's third person
that's what matters to me most with
Arcane you're I I thought surely it's
going to be first right other games are
first person um but no third person and
I can't wait to see more can't wait to
see more of it and for those asking like
Y is it a j well I just got got to see
gameplay I just got to see the gameplay
and then I'll make a
determination it feels just one I will
say that I just I just need to see the
game playay in action as far as is it a
sell shaded arti sty I don't know I
don't know based on what I seen but I
like that they set their person because
the F Point arcane's history is always
first person right so to see them say
that it's going to be that that's
tremendous and again superhero grounded
on the Xbox platform going for IP going
for pop culture that's why I've always
challenged X Box from day one I've
always said that you guys don't have
your finger on the pulse of what's
popping as far as Pop Culture blade is
an A and then think about this y'all and
it's mature and it's mature it's gy good
another complaint against Xbox games
nothing's dark it's too much colors it's
too you know what I mean even Starfield
come play be like yo it's not enough
Gore right oh you going to get vampires
you going to get Gore you going to get a
grounded car it's going to be in Paris
and then think about the tying we know
mahash Ali with the movie right not
saying that they going to be directly
related but I'm talking about from a
cross promotional standpoint it this is
tremendous for Microsoft to allow or
arcade and them to to do this because I
would assume this is after defin this is
post acquisition if I had to assume that
is tremendous I'm very proud of them I
think that's there's a couple of
characters that I really feel fit well
in video games like Daredevil blade
grounded street level where they could
be hurt cuz it's let's be honest F like
Superman and Hulk are kind of hard to do
in game because they're just so beasty
you know what I mean so this is perfect
and I love what I'm going and the last
thing I want to say is what dip down
said hell blade too all right I
apologize I've been on y'all I I but on
record I didn't want to see y'all
because my my mind I was like until
y'all show combat I really didn't want
to hear anything you talk about so in my
mind I'm like all right you come with a
direct bro not only they show the comat
it was like they were listening to me
they like all right we gonna keep giving
you comat we GNA keep showing you more
we I was all right there we go hell
Blake and it looks phenomenal outside of
trying to think what other game I would
say what was that other game that we
said oh my God that looks like the best
looking game um Wukong probably right
yeah black myth those are the only two
as far as what looks next gen to me what
like pushing the system is what Xbox
fans want to see that look phenomenal ad
we going to jump in I know yeah that's
say like shout out to hellblade
hellblade you know hellblade was the the
one that popped up and it was so oh it
really showed people it's like look like
you know I I saw people on Twitter that
were still saying they they want to see
more in depth gameplay cuz it just
showed like a bunch of like look like
executioner but uh people were saying we
already knew what the combat kind of
looked like they want to see how much
more in depth the combat is and not just
the combat cuz if you look at it and you
look at the combat from uh hellblade one
they kind of do look a similar so I can
understand the criticism on that weave
though that weave
the fire and the VIS but I but you're
fair I understand I think I think
there's fa there's some fairness there
to what people are saying but I just
needed to see I just need but continue I
see what I mean you know hellblade was
there um OD was
there um whatever that is whatever it
is like they they Xbox really showed up
to this showed out yeah they really
showed out it it was crazy man but yeah
I was then again it's so many Trail I
par to it was so many good announcements
at this show I'm going to have to go
back and look at some of those trailers
again you know on the OLED
4K watch that yeah I need to see that
hellblade at
4K and I want to point out for all the
people that's been attacking me for
years that uh Xbox don't need no uh
comic book hero G oh you saw the
reaction on Twitter you saw yeah I want
to point out to people that's been
telling me that for years yeah the
people that said they don't need that
yeah get talk to yeah I I don't see I
don't want to see you guys hype blade I
don't want to see you guys play blade I
don't want to see you guys even look at
blad Direction don't even look at it
look at like they don't need to do no
superhero that when I made the the video
Xbox needs their own superhero game all
I heard was they don't need that they
don't need to be PlayStation but now all
you sitting there you loving that blade
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah and the thing
that's interesting too is to see it's
the audience right because you you show
this at the gaming ones I know people
like yo show stuff on your own show but
to have to sit on this to have this at
the gaming ones you now have a
PlayStation audience and a Sony audience
that says yo Xbox is doing all of this
that's big it's those eyes not to
mention you you show the initial reveal
but then you show the in-depth gameplay
on your own stuff yes then you go you
know what that is addict the people that
were saying that kind of stuff about
they don't need that superer g
you still don't need a superhero game
but it's a bonus see he coming around
around coming
around superhero game but it sure does
help yeah it sure does break the
internet let's see what's trending those
are fanboys that tell us what's trending
y'all those are fanboys that don't have
any confidence in Xbox and what I mean
is they're very complacent with what
they were getting someone Xbox they felt
like they weren't ever going to get
something like that so they were just
said oh I don't want it then I I don't
want it cuz they they didn't have any
confidence in Xbox doing so and Xbox is
doing it and now they're going to turn
tail and they're going to be like oh
yeah no I I like it it's a great game
not to be messy but I'm like why is
Spider-Man 2 trending the way it is on
Twitter um disgusting film Spider-Man
210 war that the gameward that was
nominated for seven somebody on Twitter
I'm not going to say their name being
messy body Man 2 won the same I going
Awards Starfield they out of they out of
pocket they out of pocket they said yeah
so I think I was wondering yeah that is
interesting cuz I deserve to be in the
Game of the Year category it did not it
didn't deserve best narrative it didn't
deserve best Direction I I I didn't see
it for any of those three categor
actually felt like best no I don't feel
like it our best dire Adventure is the
only one I would in its spot in best
Direction because to me best direction
is is is doing stuff that else is doing
or doing it better and to me Spider-Man
is literally more 2018 just with both of
them in the same game you're right
you're right bro that's that's some of
the reason and also Starfield you can
fit how you want about Starfield but at
the same time Starfield was doing stuff
that no one else is doing yeah I just
truly believe it didn't the best
narrative it wasn't the best Direction
it would
it it's a very overrated game very
overrated game look I'm going com off
I'll be Spider-Man too but I am
surprised though I I am surp I didn't
think it would not come up with anything
actually um what was the um I was
surprised Final Fantasy 16 that the the
the actor dude but what you call it one
in that in that category but no this is
a great show it's a great show but to
addict's point yes there still we still
have a long way to go with the actual
Awards part of the show we still but we
improving we we're slowly getting there
but we still got a long way cuz again I
I'm with you I've I remember from the
the first game award they did that where
they show the category for this this
this is and the winner is this next and
and the winner is this next I was like n
we not doing that as long as cuz you
know marvel uh the people the person
that plays uh blade really pushed back
on on the movie so and they they're
re-shooting it like they redid
everything so yeah he's happy with the
direction if I was
Microsoft if I was Microsoft I would I
would be putting a lot of money behind
blade and also I I I I I would be
helping fund or whatever they have to do
the Marvel movie because if that Marvel
movie is successful it's going to
automatically generate to the game so to
me it's I'd be over there I'll be like
yo do you guys need some extra marketing
some extra funding like what you guys
need because we need that to be more
mainstream we need blade to be a
mainstream IP cuz that's going to make
our game a mainstream IP the fact that
the Marvel rep was on stage talking
about the respect he had for arcade Leon
and dishonor and death and that they
were happy with this partnership e
volumes for potential future things
right so right now a big and again this
is in the regime of ownership one their
own this is not you could tell like this
is after he said we want what were we
going to do after death loop after so
this is after the acquir that this
happened underneath the Xbox B that's
dope I'm very very excited for that
proud of the team Xbox absolutely killed
it but uh that's all I got for want
anything else I got I got I got I got
vide my mouth is feeling a little bit
better I'm not making a video tonight
I'm making one tomorrow even if I made
one tonight what I'm going to do release
it at 1: in the
morning James midnight s is a good game
tell them God yeah you can play blade
there for now to hold you down hold you
down I think I think very good show it
was definitely worth it uh you know
especially seeing what happen you know
just next year Jeff F I don't even care
if you have to make it like an extra 20
minutes long like give more of those
people time to talk like even if you
have to have them all like five or six
microphones in a line in a row and they
they what they do is they they say them
and they go to One mic another mic
another mic another mic and they just
give them all like two minutes each to
speak like it's just like it it's just I
just didn't like the three times this
man went up there and said like six
Awards in a row like at Le at least give
the dude the pre-recorded video so he
could just say his yeah that's all you
know what yeah bro thank you we won want
to shout out to the team thank you on if
they just had a montage at the end like
if you wanted to watch continue you can
watch continued on the Montage like it's
just like there's better ways to handle
the game awards than not letting the
people get the game awards but I get it
look people regardless on that that's
that's my biggest criticism but Bravo it
was a fantastic show shout out to BT
Maverick 772 Super Chat another Arcane
vampire
game that good I like that I like that
LE not
Arcane talking they breed up a red fall
one time yeah we a talk about that
that's
the I'm GNA have to get out of here guys
it's late I got to get up early get some
rest F brother you thank you for hanging
out with us I know you had a lot going
on brother and it was so good to laugh
of course yeah that's what I wanted
that's what I needed bro so thank you
thank the chat the chat was great guys
do you just want to catch these super
chats yeah I'm going to catch it right
now yeah shout out to new new new $2
Super Chat Xbox a had to go so hard my
Lord you going in Z Roman Zale I think
we got him and I'll read it anyway no
gear six no Fallout 4 next Channel
Fallout 3 remastered no desided three I
think there's going to be an Xbox show
in January it's to the point where they
got so many titles now for them to you
know the old I saw o DM blade on this
show so there's more stuff coming all
right n d Taco Super Chat hell Blade 2
with combat that's his first thing blade
announcement is his second thing the
Berserker is his third I forgot the
first Berserker yeah that was good uh
four Wukong release date yeah and five
no rest for the wicked yeah oh we forgot
about that architect Studio game that
one that made by the mass effect that
joint look crazy metaphor say I even
talk about my Sega I got the Sega even
he wasn't there yeah super game they
doing the classics and making new
versions of sh no Be Crazy Taxi oh alert
no no no we ain't going that right now I
just just you know we remember it now we
we save say and then yes Gina let's see
I got him um Nature Boy 802 chat Xbox
tax narrative should be put to bed now
LOL and then Nintendo we got him with
that on drunken Ninja oh yeah yep save
the games I want PlayStation okay
nintend H they want to give PlayStation
fans the hope that blade will be on
PlayStation for the next three years and
then rip the Band-Aid off and
make what an Xbox damn
Nintendo messy mon if y going crazy
right now Nintendo wait use a Sega I
missed this oh I gotta frame this use a
Sega fan now you like that super gay all
right that's what I'm talking about come
home brother it ain't too late we we we
taking applications
all right we got yeah I got his one
before got the okay so I think I got
everybody now except the new ones that
just came in all right so did you get
the when's the last one you read um uh
BT Maverick so JD gamer I got to get
from him on Xbox domination baby $2
Super Chat I agree with you JD he did
they did really good job they did they I
this Sunday going to be L it's going to
be crazy uh just uh just bring it with
the the two Super Chat PlayStation show
DLC Xbox show K SC wow shout out to JD
for gifting five you guys to the realm
definitely put the logos in the chat uh
then we got a member chat from God
Emperor suffa King seven months he said
blade got ponies on uh Twitter triggered
along with the coima game let the salt
flow $5 sub from JD gamer panel pick
three must has for yourself personally
personally uh super
game um um
blade I don't want to say cuz H blade we
already know so I don't want to um
everybody knows damn I think the third
one would probably be that um I said
Sega blade and that that archetype game
the I forgot the name for the people
that have Mass Effect energy they showed
it very early in the in the joint I like
the fact that there's a Mana game on
Xbox yeah that's crazy what's y'all
three games they want to know uh dip
down I the game Mana blade MH and
probably that super massive okay
okay I got a go Sega was fired I was lit
um
blade um and
then one of those anime games that c
kept coming for which one of
many many man I forgot I forgot now
you're good you're good it was a lot it
a lot of a lot of anime gam lot of stuff
cool all right guys I think we are good
yeah dip down where can if find people
find you let them know put in the chat
too dip down dip down anime if you want
to watch me and my wife just uh do funny
reactions to different anime that we
watch and then uh shout out to adct and
King for just kind of like inspiring me
to kind of get the dip down Xbox Channel
back up and running yeah guys I saw
y'all do y was working I kind of inspire
me to kind of try put some effort in
that again dip down Xbox doing some
stuff there again
mm no doubt add it yeah I'm G send you
guys over there to to J man I definitely
go over there show him some love man
he's he's a good dude app oh deala Moon
Studios new game look fire thank you so
many games so many games it was lit man
it was lit but you guys have a good day
good day everybody enjoy enjoy and
thanks for rocking with us over 700
rocking on a what you call night 1130
already almost at 10,000 views yeah
that's insane thank y'all man love y'all
see you PE